so the January 6 tapes have been
released speaker Mike Johnson has dumped
all of the footage it is now available
for you to watch and people have started
posting it online and boy oh boy what do
we see wow the police facilitating
January 6 that's not an understatement
cops are shown shaking hands in fact
they're even removing Flex cuffs from
people who were for some reason detained
and they're seen walking through the
halls with these people and there's way
more footage still to come these are
just the first few clips that have gone
up I think this debunks the Insurrection
narrative wholeheartedly I know most of
us already knew that that that narrative
was absurd but now it's going to be
interesting how this affects people who
are currently on trial because we can
see a lot of the narrative that has been
push put uh put forward about violence
doesn't apply to a large portion of
these people who were charged with
obstructing a government proceeding in
in fact in Des doa's police state one
woman mentions that her son I believe it
was her nephew who went into the capital
was there an hour after the violence in
the breach and you walk up to the
capital there's no barriers there's no
signs the doors are open cops are waving
to people shaking their hands taking
selfies how could they charge this
person with a crime and they're doing it
but now the footage is out in other news
in one of the more shocking bits of news
Michael Rapaport comedian hates Donald
Trump still hates Donald Trump and says
he is actually considering voting for
Donald Trump why likely because of his
support for Israel and what we are
seeing now we saw this in DC and we saw
it today far leftists rioting in support
of Palestine in opposition to Israel and
this is freaking out a lot of the never
trumpers and anti-trumpers and so uh
Democrats are in trouble it doesn't
matter if it's Joe Biden what matters is
that if the Democrats come out and
outright just say they're in support of
Israel they're going to lose 10% of
their voting base which is 18 to 29 so
we're going to talk about that plus the
government is coming after Elon Musk
Elon Musk says you are not allowed to
call for decolonization on Twitter
because it's a call for genocide let's
jump over to cast brew.com before we get
started and and you should all go and
buy the best cup of coffee you'll ever
have we have our rise with Roberto Jr
Halloween special edition where our dead
mascot Roberto Jr's foot is erupting
from the earth this will uh once it's
gone it's gone we've printed 5,000 of
these bags and uh get them while you can
but everyone's favorite of course is
rise with Junior breakfast blend is
incredible to light roast and appalachin
nights when you buy C Brew Coffee what
are you doing we are building physical
coffee shops the first one is underway
the professional equipment has arrived
some of it's uh uh being checked you
know we're working on it we are working
on franchising agreements and other
systems nothing's there yet I got to be
very careful how I phrase this but we
are working on a very big plan if you
like the idea of physical locations
where people can hang out and us moving
into the physical space so that when you
come into a coffee shop to have coffee
what do you see on the TV you say
timcast you see stick sex and Hammer you
see Steven Crowder that's the point go
to casper.com support our work but also
don't forget go to
timcast.net a new Doc we just put out
show it to your friends bring it go go
to your local bar say hey let me log in
and play this documentary in the
background let people watch this it's
fun it's exciting it's informative and
it helps people understand gun culture
and the importance of keeping and uh
bearing arms so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Clint
what's up Tim thank you for having me
back well I I'm just so happy that we
got rid of that terrorist sympathizing
dead weight and Dave Smith now we can
really talk about how great Israel is
I'm really pumped to be here uh I'm the
host of liberty lockdown I'm also the
co-host of tower gang and I am the new
co-host of a fantastic show called the
best political show.com it's exclusive
over on Rumble you can find it we are
change all one word myself in lukew CI
it's going to be a blast and I cannot
wait to get into it right on we got Phil
oh Phil
hi how you doing I'm Phil abanti lead
singer of All That Remains very failed
musician anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary and I'm here with
my friend Ian yes hello thank you I have
been on the best political show with you
and Luke and it was awesome it was great
it ITT it stood up to its name I was
enjoyed it quite a bit second best but
it's okay it's the best political
show.com I imagine that website's taken
too yeah we got it while you're there
pick up uh the take the chill pill.com
and get some supplements I know that uh
we are change are producing those take
the chill pill.com there you go man
what's happening Serge yo I am here
ready for the Friday show let's get to
it to here we go from the post
millennial breaking all January uh 6
footage publicly released by house
Speaker Mike Johnson I'd like to just
pause and say dude why on a Friday come
on on a Friday we know why he did it he
had to do it this shows they really
didn't want to do it but okay fine it
finally happened do you think it's
better to do it on this Friday
considering next week is like if you did
it on Monday it's a it's a holiday
that's the perfect time to do it
absolutely it's Thanksgiving dude next
week we are not going to be here
Thursday and Friday we will have a
culture War episode up Friday but this
is the perfect time to drop on a Tuesday
right before Thanksgiving so when
everyone is at their home with their
liberal ant that can be like what do you
mean all the footage just got released
here it is now to be fair to be fair you
can still do that no one's saying you
can't but uh it doesn't hit the press
the same way so he could have released
this earlier in the week but fine so be
it now uh this is the this is the big
news my Johnson says today I'm keeping
my promise to the American people and
making all the January 6 tapes available
to all Americans bang There It Is take a
look at this we got it all baby it's uh
right here at cha.
house.gov subcommittee blah blah blah
blah blah the link has been uh uh
published online by tons of people on
Twitter and uh we've got some of these
clips hey here you go here's a video of
a police officer shaking a dude's and as
as they're walking through the cops
clearly don't care anybody is here
they're not asking any anybody to leave
now I understand that in some
circumstances people were fighting with
police yep those violent people should
be arrested and charged I understand in
some circumstances the cops are on
camera saying guys you need to leave
totally get it however the point is a
large majority of what happened happened
well after the violence on the other
side of the building and the police not
only allow it to happen but were
actually look people they were allowed
to leave they walk right in right out
there was no no effort At All by any of
the officers to stop this and you you
want I'll tell you this right now as
someone with experience in fact I think
in this video you've got a guy where
there's a video where someone gets his
cuts his cuffs removed I don't know if I
have that one pulled up actually but uh
actually yeah was it this one let me see
if it's this video right here no maybe
not just a cop shaking some guy's hand
it was a shorter one let me let me tell
you about uh uh protests in New York
City in Washington DC how about this in
Washington DC DC on January 20th 2017
around
215 far- leftists were all caught by the
police and arrested as a single group
what did the police do stood in a circle
around them that's it they stood in a
circle around and said you're not free
to go and what did everyone do stood
there you mean to tell me the
insurrectionists are in the building and
the cops are like here you are sir the
exit is Right This Way shakes his hand
takes a selfie and now they're going to
criminally charge these people the best
example as I mentioned earlier is from
dases doosa police state documentary
it's not the best example there's
several examples where a woman says her
nephew showed up an hour after so the
doors are open there's no barricades
there's the the cops have let everybody
in and he walks up and he's like hi
how's it going come on in apparently he
walks around and then he leaves and
they've given him all of these charges
they want to lock him up forever I met a
woman who said her and her husband
showed up an hour or so after all the
violence to this exact story there were
no barricades they' been removed the
doors had been uh propped open by the
police the police had waved people in
and they showed up waving little Flags
having no idea what was going on now
they're being sent to jail over this was
there was there any uh followup to that
reporting from a few days ago about
those buses that allegedly had like
Undercovers ghost buses yeah was that
was that verifi okay no the media is
calling that one a conspiracy theory
okay well maybe it is well no are you
are you joking it means in three months
that'll be proven true oh right I me
come on what are you doing here just
like the Wuhan Institute of rology we'll
figure out about you know shortly look I
I mean I think that anybody that's
followed this story closely has known
for since day five after j6 that this
was uh largely overblown so I'm not
exactly surprised but I I just hope that
this helps in bringing Justice I would
like an explanation from Johnson the new
speaker as to you know what was the hold
up I would like to know actually from
the the the old guard why why did it
take two and a half years for us to get
this information it seems so obviously
necessary that we get to see it I feel
like there's been people in Congress
like there's enough information where
you can kind of say yeah the federal
government is behaving outside of what
is legal right like it's pretty clear
that they're using you know false pre
pretenses to punish political dissidents
and punish people for their political
agendas and I don't know why there
aren't more people in Congress that are
actually saying it there's a handful of
people that are actually talking about
it but most of them don't actually want
to make a firm statement about the
violations of the law and violations of
of American Americans rights that the
current Administration is is doing I
have a thesis for you please by all
means my my thesis would be that uh
people you know representatives in
Congress or in Senate have watched the
FBI worked surreptitiously to try and
undermine Donald Trump I mean they they
tried to impeach him twice off of
totally faulty information you had uh
false affidavits that were filed by FBI
agents these people are scared to death
of speaking out against the the you know
FBI the CIA the entire uh intelligence
agency apparatus and I don't blame them
but we need courage right now that's the
problem is that these people are just
not being courageous and that's what
we've actually put them there to be
everyone on the January 6 subcommittee
should be expelled from Congress agreed
they they they lied manipulated to steal
political power and the sad thing is we
all know it we've always known it and
these changes will not come however that
being said the the uh uh what happened
in Israel has really been a lightning
bolt on this country a a a a an
earthquake of such such tremendous
magnitude the left is ripped to shreds
and seeing these people say they're
going to vote for Trump we'll get into
this a little bit later but I'm actually
more optimistic than I've ever been when
I see hardcore never trumpers being like
I'll vote for the guy really now I got
to tell you something really crazy about
that January 6 was supposed to be an
Insurrection where they tried to
overthrow the United States and take it
over and now you've got people not they
don't care anymore because of Israel
again I know I know we we'll get into
this a little bit later but my point is
when it comes to January 6 subcommittee
their goal was Insurrection they set in
those committee hearings withholding
information lying about what was going
on why to steal political power that is
an Insurrection that is seditious
conspiracy and these videos only prove
more of what we already knew the cops
are waving people in and shaking their
hands right how can you call that an
Insurrection but it it doesn't actually
begin then it it began I mean it may
have even begun earlier than this but
the the most obvious example to me is
when you have you know the spying that's
happening on the Trump campaign before
he's even elected president you know and
you have Obama yeah and that was
directed by Obama and Hillary Clinton um
but you know Biden also it was writing
shotgun for much of that so it it just
seems absolutely absar to me that the
the representatives in Congress Congress
aren't willing to actually speak out
about how perilous these circumstances
are you know you know what Obama
addressed Obama understood what hurt
Nixon and uh you know what hurt Nixon
the press and so Obama said if I am
going to commit a engage in a seditious
conspiracy after murdering American
citizens and bombing children to other
countries he said if I am going to try
and steal power and destroy the United
States uh uh uh government and this
country and the lives of the American
people I will have to own the Press
before I do it m and the reason why he
has not been he has not gone down as one
of the worst Presidents in history is
because the Press has just kept lying in
his defense but I truly hope I hope that
within seven within eight years the
narrative has flipped on the horror that
was the Obama Administration The
Psychotic deranged and evil things that
man did let's just talk about the
killing of Abdul ran alaki let's talk
about the extra judicial assassinations
of several others let's talk about the
National Defense authorization act
indefinite detention provision in which
Obama said he had the right to take you
in secret in the middle of the night to
an offshore military vessel a naval
vessel and torture you that's it that's
the a decree he made he prosecuted more
whistleblowers and journalists on the
Espionage Act than any other president
and he spied on Donald Trump working
with Hillary Clinton we know this and
still he gets he gets pass all this why
he owned the Press well and he also want
to know Nobel Peace Prize for nothing
for nothing to top all that off he was
given a Nobel Peace Prize he didn't win
but but let let me just add one more
item that's you know in my wheelhouse as
to reasons to not like uh Barack Obama
he was responsible for the executive
order that implemented diversity Equity
inclusion in every Federal uh Department
across our government that was his his
action the last month of Trump's
presidency he tried to undo it and then
the very first day of Biden's presidency
they redid it that's how that's how
important this is to them that they are
able to uh essentially divide and
conquer which is exactly what Dei is
even though it's about diversity right
but really what it is is about
oppression Olympics and it's dividing
and making us all you know become at
each other's throats it's terrible why
did Trump wait till the end of his
tenure to do that I couldn't tell you
because it yeah he could have done at
any point I think I think Tim's right he
doesn't know what he's doing
unfortunately which is why I like V so
much because I know for a fact he
understands exactly what I'm talking
about man is it is I'm I I I I I'd love
to imagine a v ramaswami presidency day
one but I you need more than just
unfortunately you need more than the
knowhow to win a like right to win right
and and Viv may be the best day one he
goes in with a scalpel an obsidian blade
and just perfectly perfectly excises all
of the rot and helps turn this country
around I mean but winning is something
different I know and and I think Trump
is clearly in the cat bird seat if you
will to to to win again but um you know
I'm still holding out hope that if it if
vake uh you know broadens his Horizons
and he's willing to consider a VP slot
with Trump I I think that would be
probably as good as I could hope for in
terms of a winning ticket that would
actually deliver much of what the
Libertarians would like to see not not
all of it obviously but much I'm just I
I just like to see people get fired me
too brother I'd like to then see after
that some criminal prosecution yes thank
you
yeah I mean there's there's this uh you
know misunderstanding about Libertarians
and anarcho capitalists that like we
don't want you know we don't believe in
the state so we don't want to see
criminals put in behind bars like
couldn't be further from the truth like
you can't speak for all Libertarians
they get pissed off when you do that
kind of stuff well I'm going to do it
anyways uh don't really care they can
get mad at me uh yeah I think if there's
one group of people that all
Libertarians agree ought to be behind
bars it's corrupt politicians that are
ruling over us against our will you know
from Jump Street well Phil would you
agree
uh well I'm not a Libertarian but uh no
but from your perspective in your
opinion you said people don't like
talking for Libertarians but you think
Libertarians want to see the corrupt
politicians locked up I think that there
there is the most uh if there is a rule
for the state then policing corruption
is probably among the the most
fundamental things that the state should
have to do I mean you don't want a state
that's that's passing a lot of laws
anyways you you want to let you want to
keep laws as
local and low impact as possible um but
if you've got people that are entrusted
with uh with creating law then I think
that the policing of those people is
among the most important that a state do
I'd like to point something very
important out you know these videos are
not the only videos we have proving the
Capitol Police were aiding and abetting
the January 6 Insurrection there's
videos of them opening the doors there's
videos of them waving people in there's
a video of one of them wearing a manga
hat and waving people in there's a video
of them shaking hands now there's more
videos of them shaking hands releasing
people from Flex cuffs giving them
directions to insurrectionists and the
most important thing the Capitol Police
have been expanded under the Biden
Administration into new locations which
would mean the Capitol Police the
principal and most powerful organization
involved in facilitating the January 6
Insurrection have been given more power
by the Biden Administration which would
mean Joe Biden himself is engaged in an
Insurrection by aiding and abetting
insurrectionists and therefore is
disqualified under the 14th Amendment
fire him that's some uh Fanny Willis
judicial work there I don't care I want
to see the F paperwork look if they're
going to if they're going to claim
Donald Trump did this that or otherwise
it's all Bs nonsense I just gave you all
your novel legal Theory roll with it
file the lawsuits yes they're losing but
do it anyway the uh you had Lauren de
Laguna on your show last week and made
she made an interesting point that
sometimes you you people are guilty of
crimes you don't want to prosecute them
for the betterment of society like
that's a legal philosophy and there are
times and places when you would not
prosecute even though they've done
something wrong I thought that was
interesting considering our current
political Paradigm and the whole tit
fortat I'll get your guy and in four
years you're going to get me and then
four years after that someone's going to
come and get you back like maybe there's
a see this is the problem with that cuz
I am a very forgiving person and I'm
also so Buddhist meditating type like
yourself so uh the the issue that I have
is that it's not tit forat it's One
Direction give me give me an example
like a real example of a Democrat who
plays ball with the establishment that
actually sees like hard time Behind Bars
it's very rare right it's very very rare
um so the issue is not so much that you
know the GOP is being persecuted it's
that the the left is never being
persecuted so if that's the case you
don't have Justice at all well to be
fair Eric Adams
uh in New York you know he gets upset
about immigration so what happens oh the
feds come crashing down he didn't play
ball right right and I mean that's
that's really startling because you know
he was the mayor of New York City right
is the mayor of New York C is is sorry
I'm already Assuming he's out um but
yeah I mean we've got two three million
illegal immigrants that are coming
across the border many of them are are
making their way to New York and their
infrastructure is you know basically
being overran and and he's doing his job
but just because that goes against the
the kind of neoliberal narrative about
open borders and that uh immigration at
any magnitude is acceptable well then
you can't talk about it even though it's
going to bankrupt his City and that's
just the reality Let's uh let's jump to
some Modern politics let's talk about I
I got some good news for everybody this
is a tweet that's been uh reposted by
Libby Emmons it is of Michael rapor A
man who utterly despises Donald Trump
and still to this day despises Donald
Trump but uh this comedian this man who
hat hat Donald Trump I'll say it again
has a message for all of you y'all ready
to hear it if it comes down to Pig dick
Donald
Trump and smoking Joe
Biden I'm
sorry I am
sorry voting for pig dick Donald Trump
is on the table oh I'm sorry I'm
so I'll still call him slob dick Donald
Trump Pig dick Donald Trump and all
that but we to get this whole
situation under control and you know
what that situation is he's talking
about he's talking about far leftists
that are storming uh trying to storm the
DNC they're storming into I think a
university a few hours ago he's talking
about the far-left protesters in New
York City cheering on Hamas and I just
think it's absolutely
hilarious that this guy who hates Donald
Trump and I'm not going to speak to him
as what he's as to what he said about
January 6 but the fact that so many
people are moving in this direction
despite screaming that Donald Trump is a
fascist hitlerian psychopath who tried
to overthrow the US government they
genuinely claimed they claimed that
Donald Trump was a threat to this
country but then Israel got threatened
and now all of a sudden it's like oh I
don't care about this country I'll vote
for Donald Trump yeah as long as we get
what we want over there huh kind of
shows what his priorities are but I'm
just heartbroken I'm heartbroken because
this guy was in True Romance which is
one of my favorite movies ever and he's
now just like a you know a character of
himself look so outside outside of that
I'll just say this I'm not going to I
don't want to rag on rap um he's allowed
to hate TR Donald Trump that's totally
fine I I I don't know what he said about
January 6 I'd be willing to bet he said
a lot of crazy things uh uh CR critical
things of trump fine if he's coming out
now and saying hey man I'm starting to
realize these far leftists are crazy and
this is what it took I'll take what I
can get I'm not going to I'm not going
to push him away anybody who comes to me
and says I didn't realize the far-left
wanted to kill you know uh uh let's just
be very careful supported Hamas that to
a great proportion supported Hamas and
were posting images of paragliders
coming into is very delicate here they
didn't know that so be it I will say
shake my hand buddy we're going to vote
for Donald Trump together right well
look that's fair I but I just don't I
don't look at rapid port and his
unhinged Behavior over the past four
years and go like like this is an ally
in any former fashion yeah he may vote
for Trump he might but he's still he's
just as crazy as the people that are
Marching for Hamas I but but look he can
say whatever he wants he can believe
whatever he wants but if we truly
believe and you you probably don't but
I'm saying for me that Donald Trump is
our best path forward in 2024 for a
variety of reasons if this guy is saying
he's gonna he's going to help me out
with that I I say yes here's here's way
I was talking to Scott Horton after the
show uh great dude we had him on culture
war and I said look man if I see Donald
Trump and he's having a snowball fight
with Hillary Clinton
and he's just whipping them at her and
she's getting hit and she's about to be
knocked off her bouns into a nice snow
pile it's all good fun everybody it's
all good fun and then he runs out of
snowballs and he looks at me and he goes
Tim I need one more one more snowball
I'm gonna throw him a snowball if
Michael rapor is the guy who's got I'll
be like let's go and if he throws a
snowball to Trump and then Trump whips
one last snowball hitting Hillary and
she falls backwards into the snow you
get my point I'm very nice okay we're
having a very fun familyfriendly game of
a snowball fight and Hillary falls down
and then she giggles and laughs and
everyone's happy but Trump wins that's
my point look i' I've said before you
know I'm not a trump supporter but I
don't disagree with you that he's
probably the best bet at getting me any
closer to what I want to see but I just
don't have any confidence in him because
of what happened during 2020 and that's
the reason I don't I don't support him
um but yeah I I think that obviously if
it's if it's Gavin Nome like I would be
I would be out of my mind not to prefer
Trump over Nome you going to vote for
him probably
not probably not well I'll put it like
this I'd vote for him I'll put it like
this hold on I'll put it like this if
I'm in a swing state which currently I
am I'm in Florida wait are you joking
isn't it a swing state no well I mean it
went very hard for disantis but it's
been a swing state historically so not
even for no I think for trump it was
even it was even better okay well then I
don't if my vote doesn't matter you know
who I'm voting for uh but if it if it's
if if there's some theoretical
possibility that my vote will actually
swing things then yeah maybe I'd
consider Trump but look I'm not look
you're putting me in a corner Tim don't
make me endorse this guy no I don't have
to do this you don't have to endorse
Trump you can even outright say he's
awful but man like I said if Donald
Trump is the one who's engaging in that
snowball fight against the The
Establishment machine and the war
machine I'm like the look no new Wars he
that dude tried so hard to get us out of
Syria I'm just like I was saying this to
Dave Smith not not the LA yesterday but
the last time I was here I was like come
on man I know the drone strikes are bad
I know the bombing in Afghanistan was
bad but he set a timeline there were no
new Wars he tried getting our troops out
of Syria if I can take an inch from
anybody back towards pulling our troops
I will take it to you know to your point
there like and this is one of my
frustrations with Libertarians is
they're always so they're so frequently
looking for Purity and if you look like
to look at the United States government
and the United us Empire Global Empire
with military bases and 120 or something
countries around the world the idea that
you should throw
away someone that is trying
to trying to pull back on the US
government trying to actually make real
Cuts because they were unsuccessful when
literally you're going to have the most
powerful government in all of human
history working against you because that
government has incentive to stop you
from making Cuts so for for for
Libertarians to do to to say things like
oh you know that guy's total garbage
because he he there were some Wars or
there were still Wars going on or he
didn't end all the wars it's like think
about the task that you're demanding
this person do immediately or within
four years with the amount of resistance
that they're going to have to deal with
it is outside of realistic to say this
person was elected and they didn't undo
do 250 years of encroachment on your
Liberties and blah blah blah in four
years so we they're all bad that is
ridiculous a bit of a strong man of my
position though no no I'm not saying
it's you I'm saying I'm saying there are
there are Libertarians like that you're
absolutely right but here's the reality
he he did not try to shrink the size of
the government he did try to end some
unconstitutional legal Wars and God
bless him for that but he also increased
the size of the federal government
significantly and he stood by during the
most catastrophic decision of any
president in my lifetime and in terms of
domestic policy which was the covid
lockdowns and that's that is the like
honest to God if it if it weren't for
2020 I probably would have supported
Donald Trump I probably would have I I
think I I actually I think it's fair I I
view it this way like the libertarian
argument you've got two guys who go back
and forth whacking you with a stick and
then finally you get a guy who's like no
no no no he hit you 10 times I'm going
to hit you eight times so vote for me
and the reformist argument is just take
the eight wax instead of the 10 and then
the argument is screw you all I'm not
I'm not playing your game so I can
respect that I can my attitude is just I
think the the the best I I I choose the
reformer position of man I know Trump is
far from perfect but he was a net
positive and that's all that matters
well I I think on domestic policy and
changing the dialogue amongst the
American people He was largely a net
positive the issue is that for whatever
reason being a businessman being a
businessman myself I don't understand
why he doesn't understand fed policy
more why he doesn't understand that his
brow beating of uh I don't know if it
was pal at the time I think it was but
trying to drive down interest rates even
lower uh you know wanting to pass
trillions of dollars in stimulus
spending during the co era without votes
without roll call votes trying to evict
Massie who's the greatest Congressman of
the past decade out of power because he
wanted to have a roll call vote to have
people on record for a $3 trillion
spending bill which is something that
historically we would have never even
considered as being feasible there's
just a lot of behaviors from him that
goes counter to this narrative that he
is actually a small government guy no
he's demat but but that's not even
that's not even my point cuz I don't
disagree with you the only thing I
disagree with on is Massie I would say
Matt Gates especially considering the
fight with uh uh uh um with McCarthy
sure but you know Massie is pretty great
I'm a big fan uh although you know he
very much supported McCarthy we know
that McCarthy behind the scenes was
sabotaging people and I agree and that's
bizarre it's insane and brutal but it
really comes down to for me I mean
typically the most important thing thing
is is foreign policy and my attitude has
has has long been I mean this is just
how I grow up that the United States
bickers amongst it amongst its own
people about the things we deserve and
the things we've done wrong while
everyone ignores the bombing the
humanitarian crisis the arming the the
massacres I mean and and this is this is
what this is why I mean it's kind of
crazy to think it was Obama before
Donald Trump so we get Donald Trump and
I'm like what's going on things are
actually kind of okay like what do we
have what do we have with Barack Obama
extrajudicial extrajudicial
assassinations how many weddings did he
blow up the the expansion of middle M
Middle Eastern conflict Syria look at
Libya this these outright disasters
these hospitals too blw up hospitals no
question Donald Trump did better than
Barack Obama a million ways when it
comes to foreign policy MH not perfect a
lot of bad things too so for me it's
kind of like this uh I've had friends
who are like we deserve Healthcare and
I'm like okay let's talk about after we
stop blowing up kids in Yemen and and
Pakistan aged and so when Donald Trump
comes in and he's like no new Wars
timeline for getting our troops out get
our troops out of Syria and we watch the
Deep State lie to the American people
and Trump to keep troops in Syria the
only like I'll tell you Trump should not
have fired 59 tomahawk missiles at Syria
that's the one time the Press started
praising him right or or the Moab yeah
so I look at anything else and my view
really is y'all can disagree with me by
all means spam in the chat ones my
attitude is my priorities over uh my
view of say like covid lockdown stuff
and Donald Trump's role in it is a much
lower priority to the United States
spending American taxpayer dollars or
what I should say is extracting our
buying power in order to wage war in
foreign countries so when someone says
yeah but Trump did this Co thing I'm
like you know what I gotta be honest I'd
be willing to accept Penance in in terms
of some detriment to my quality of life
if it means the US stopped doing all of
that to be fair the reality is the
inverse if the US stops doing all that
in fact there's quite a good argument
our lives would improve I agree that's
that's a I'll take Trump that's a really
important point because there's this
there's this kind of myth that I think
that the American people have been sold
that in some way we have benefited the a
the average American has somehow
benefited from the Empire it couldn't be
further from the truth our purchasing
power is declining very rapidly all of
the people that have actually benefited
from it have been the worst corporations
if not in modern era
then maybe in all of human history some
of the worst actors out there the
boeings and all these other companies
that are actually literally just
profiting by the billions based off of
uh death and destruction of innocent
people it's horrific um but there's this
there's this belief that like we have to
police the world to kind of make it safe
for the global economy that people
people don't consider the fact that all
of these other nations have the same
imperative they have the same desire to
have safe shipping lanes it's there is
no there there is no actual requirement
that the American government be the
policemen of the world we ought to
handle Regional security Russia and
China ought to be handling their their
portions of the Pacific to keep it safe
and we ought to be handling ours but
that's not how it's been it's been the
American Empire is expected to go and
police everything and it is absolutely
bankrupting us can I can I I just want
to point something out too Bas on what I
just said I mean I don't know if it's
coincidental at all that 2019 we see the
best numbers of Our Lives economically
talking I'm not talking about government
spending and stuff we can absolutely
criticize all that but unemployment is
way down wage growth is improving people
are are are expressing this in polls at
the same time that Donald Trump is
actively working against the War Machine
and I'm not saying I can definitively
prove one for one that's what it's all
about but I would like to just live in
that reality so by all means please
knock me out of it prove to me that our
economy doing doing well in this time
frame and Donald Trump's positions on
rejecting Wars are totally unrelated but
I will accept it and I will roll that
dice again yeah if Donald Trump can
recreate 2018 and
2019 and and further those missions it's
just it's there and let him let him say
all the naughty things let him say all
the nasty things and all of my like my
views on on how bad 2020 was I'm just
like if the end result is we go through
a hard period but four years later our
borders are more secure manufacturing
has come back we're no longer doing
these in insane trade deals with China
the American economy has dramatically
improved and the Foreign Wars have been
whittel down the US now our allies are
actually paying their fair share as we
pull our troops back because they
shouldn't be in many of these countries
I mean that is like a dream yeah I I
don't see I I don't think that Donald
Trump as a gene who can make it all just
perfectly come true right but we had a
little taste of it in his first term and
it wasn't so bad I get so bad I get I
get the argument I totally get the
argument that here's the issue because I
come from the Austrian economics
backdrop and because I was a finance guy
I look at this and I and I look at the
the elevated inflationary pressure that
we're dealing with with nearing on$ 34
trillion in our national debt you have
all of the debt carry that's necessary
for that debt that is that is ultimately
going to really put a damper on growth
you know GDP broadly I think that we're
we're facing a very severe recession the
other thing that people aren't really
privy to is that because of the elevated
interest rate cycle all of the long-term
uh debt instrument that the banks filled
their their books with over the past
couple years when the interest rates
were at record lows those are now upside
down to the tunes of billions and
billions and billions of dollars so you
have a a potential banking contagion
simult coinciding perfectly with a
potential uh National you know debt and
Fiat crisis and then you also have the
potential for a global recession so
we're the reason I I bring all this up
is to say if you don't have someone
who's in power soon very very soon that
is actually equipped to handle this
we're in a lot of trouble and that
that's the primary reason that I can't
give any sort of real endorsement for
Donald Trump is that he has not
demonstrated a capacity to wrap his head
around the severity of the situation
that that we that approaches us and I
feel like V gets that and that's the
primary reason that if I had my brothers
the vake over over Trump all day Trump
ramaswami 2024 would you vote for it
probably yeah I definitely I mean there
question I'd vote for Trump ham sandwich
2024 just because you know obviously I
would still rather a Libertarian get in
there that's that's setting that aside
because I understand how severe the
financial situation is and because
everyone I know and love lives here and
I know that their retirement is on the
line and their way of life is on the
line their Safety and Security is
ultimately on the line with all of these
potential fronts for World War III it's
super important that we get someone in
there that is both non interventionist
but also a fiscal Hawk we need both of
those things very very very soon we
cannot continue to wait for a hero but
we need we need real changes on the on
the most important things that's why
it's a great argument to say support V
and when it comes to Trump accept Trump
yeah well and and if if V is actually
there to advise him I would have a lot
more faith in Donald Trump I I I I hope
and I beg and I pray that the very least
whatever happens V has some kind of
advisory role with the Trump
Administration if he doesn't it would be
a huge miscalculate in fact it would
demonstrate that Donald Trump hasn't
learned anything from filling his
cabinet with some of the worst warhawks
on Earth I'd still take
it I mean you're much you're much more
forgiving than me too but it's not about
forgiving it's about you can options
yeah yeah yeah yeah I understand you
could say Donald Trump is bad for all
these reasons and I'll say yep and if
it's no new Wars if if dead stop in
foreign invasion is all we get that's
four years I'll take yeah like I mean I
would love to see you know the good Dr
Ron Paul run again and and i' love to
see him win um I'd love to see anyone
that's going to make significant cuts at
the bureau you know bureaucratic level
I'd love to see cabinet level positions
totally abolished but if all I can get
is Donald Trump then it's better than
you know four more years of Biden or the
the actual problem stuff too that's even
even getting it's a big problem it's a
it is really it is really tearing at the
fabric of civilization listen not not
for nothing but like all the the people
that are pro Palestine in the US they're
not pro Palestine because they're they
have an affinity for Islam they're Pro
Palestine because they they they
understand it as a colonizer versus
colonized yes uh Dynamic it comes from
the critical theory and
decolonization just means kill the
people that have the power now that's
all it means straight up France Fannon
didn't mince words in The Wretched of
the earth and it clear he clearly said
ideally the colonized will become the
colonizer he will take his property he
will sleep in his bed and under best
circumstances he'll sleep with his wife
that's what decolonization means so I
don't entertain any of the left framing
that or any of the framing from the left
that isn't directly in like Gaza like I
get why the people in Gaza are pissed
off when you're dealing with westerners
that are taking the side of Gaza or
taking taking a side against Israel it's
all because of leftist decolonization
garbage and it that stuff will come here
if we allow those arguments to to be
made here but let me pull up this tweet
from Elon Musk violence we we got this
tweet here from Elon himself he said as
I said earlier this week decolonization
and from The River To The Sea and
similar euphemisms necessarily imply
genocide clear call calls for extreme
violence are against our terms of
service and will result in suspension
this is also in response to swipe right
here's he's responding to himself yes
decolonization necessarily implies a
Jewish genocide thus it is unacceptable
to any reasonable person and this is
what Colin Wright had said to which Elon
M responded decolonization is the woke
version of jihad and it should be viewed
and treated that way right responded to
Elon by saying exactly when Hamas
slaughtered Israeli civilians in the
name of jihad on October 7th the woke
said this is what decolonization looks
like when they when they tell us
decolonization looks like Jihad we
should believe them yes now here's the
question uh do we agree with a social
media platform Banning people calling
for decolonization or for that matter
even Jihad no I think I think that it
should be looked at just just as just
like any other time when someone calls
for violence so if you if you have a a a
platform that says we don't allow calls
for violence then talking about
decolonization and stuff then that's
consider violence in my opinion if you
don't if you allow anything then fine
you know if if x if x allows other calls
for violence and then they specifically
say we don't like this yeah that's what
I feel like too they're crime call
calling people to commit violence is a
crime now the question is decolonization
sits at that Nexus point between
academic rhetoric and instructing people
to go and commit acts of violence it's
not illegal so what they try doing is
they say we're not calling for violence
we're saying decolonize but we know what
decolonized means they called for
violence if it's not an imminent threat
with a day and a time it's not illegal
the question is it knowing that this is
not illegal should it be banned but
there's been there's
been selective enforcement of calls for
violence and things that are and are not
violence there's been there one the left
does tend to swear up and down that
things are not calls for violence that
clearly are calls for violence they say
that the protests and the the riots they
say that those aren't violence there's
there is a an ambiguity that the left
continues to rely on when they're
talking about things that they would
call direct action or riots are the
cries of the unheard yeah that it it's
exactly but it's I age that's a fair
point I think it is a fair point but it
it's still not referring to it still
obfuscates the violent nature of it what
what what Phil is referring to is how
the left will say we're going to engage
in a direct action everyone wear all
black and masks and gloves and show up
at this time at this location and what
is directed action mean direct action
literally means breaking the law or
committing acts of violence I am not I'm
not going to be cute and I'm not going
to defend the left I have been at way
too many leftist protests when they talk
about peacefully protesting that's not
what direct action is direct action is a
phrase they come up with when they're
referring to either blocking streets
blocking doors fighting with cops or
throwing things is is that is that just
antifa that that does the direct direct
action stuff the Black Block so in the
early in in the uh uh early OCC at
occupy I don't want to say early days
cuz this goes way back but I I do want
to give a shout out to our good friends
who participated in the battle in
Seattle which was a protest against the
WTO by the way by the left for some
reason now they're on the other side of
this but uh in New York we didn't call
them antifa we just call them the black
block and and we didn't call them
anarchists either sometimes the word
Anarchist gets thrown around because
it's used to convey the idea that
everyone understands like if someone
says the anarchists we know they're
referring to the people wearing all
black however considering that half the
people I don't claim them but
considering half the people we were
friends with were literal anarchists
Reed that false philosophy of
authoritarianism we knew that wasn't
correct we just called them the black
block leftists or block extremist or the
black block now everyone refers to it as
antifa cu the game they played back then
was there is no black block Black Block
is a tactic not a thing right Black
Block is when people wear hoodies and
it's like then why do the same people
all the time have logos and wear the
same clothes now it's same thing with
antifa antifa is just an idea it's not a
group there's cells there's chapters
they engage in violence this is exactly
why I or this is this is indicative of
the
actual vulnerability that liberalism has
liberalism takes the opposing view or
the argument from from someone else
takes it at face value and treats every
argument as if it is a honest argument
and if you're dealing with progressives
or socialist people that essentially
disregard or reject the Enlighten
Enlightenment values they don't see a
reason to be honest because power is the
goal not honesty so if they are looking
to win and they want to they want to go
ahead and cover up violent actions or or
or you know direct your attention
elsewhere they have no problem lying see
here here's my my interest at this
Junction being that I'm not really on
the left or the right uh is that I just
want to see this deescalate and I do not
want to I don't want to ever endorse
censorship protocols uh particularly if
they are kind of vague platitudes like
from the river to the sea or
decolonization like that is that is just
clearly not explicit enough of a threat
for it to to be illegal it's certainly
not illegal read France Fanon wretched
of the world and it's clear but Phil
it's not
illegal legality legality not but
legality is not the standard that's
something I brought up he has brought
that up he said it's it's legal or
lawful but not awful remember when he
was talking about that or maybe it was
his CEO that was saying it he he Elon
Musk point was that you're not allowed
to call for extreme violence on their
platform he did not say it has to be
illegal I said that I I know but in the
past in the past either yakar lawful but
awful yes exactly where he said if it's
lawful well I don't think any Court in
the country you could actually said all
lawful speech would be permitted on the
platform well I thought I took the
lawful uh awful but lawful as being like
that was where the gr area so that was a
direct reference to what they would
censor
things that were lawful but awful would
be censored oh it was that direction
okay well then I misunderstood so what
what their what their point was if it is
lawful but awful we will restrict it and
hide it or worse and who get to Define
what off exactly this is the problem Cal
Authority I I have no idea like once you
once you've gone down this path we I
mean we've already done this before
that's what's so frustrating just a
couple years ago we were doing this
Rumble we've been going through with
Rumble everyone's up in arms about
Rumble right now dude it's a same
rumble's going to get hit with this
Chris is going to make some stupid call
that bans some dumb thing and Chris I'm
not I will put you on the spot cuz you
haven't called me back lately but uh
it's serious man you got to decentralize
that platform holding this stuff in one
Central Area is a massive vulnerability
and people can go crazy the FBI can take
your look elon's whole claim elon's
whole claim for why he purchased Twitter
or X was that he understands allegedly
how important open dialogue and
conversation are it the entire when when
it was the left when it was hold on hold
when it was the left that was in control
that was that was absolutely Banning
anybody that was even like one degree to
the right all all my libertarian friends
got banned too so I I took this
personally the the issue is that we
understand that we're we're prepared in
the battle in the the arena of ideas we
fear no man I want to I want to have
these conversations I don't want to see
these people banned that just
radicalizes them further but you're
talking about so it's one thing to say
that you're going to look that you're
you want your platform to be an open
exchange of IDE IDE then the point is we
are not going to censor perspectives
we're not going to censor ideas right so
that's one thing but then it's one thing
to that's another that's different from
saying I want to kill all those people
right the the old Twitter the reason
that musk bought it was because there
were entire ideas that were un that were
not allowed to be articulated it wasn't
that you couldn't say the nword or the k
word or whatever swear it wasn't about
vulgarity the vulgarity is what ends up
getting people in trouble it's not you
like you're never going to see martyr
made get booted from X because of the
way because the way that he talks about
stuff like he the whole Fear and
Loathing in in New Jerusalem that whole
thing if he didn't come at the stories
the way that he does and articulate them
the way that he does if he if he did it
Loosely and like he was posting and
stuff that that all that stuff would be
like anti-Semitism get out of here if he
was approaching it by being vulgar and
stuff but the the idea is completely
fine to share those ideas on X just so
long as you're not ship posting about
them because the ship hosting is what
ends up offending people so in in on
hold on on X it's not censoring ideas
and it used to be before musk there were
entire ideas that you were not allowed
to share you couldn't say that some that
a that a man could not be become a woman
that would offend someone and that would
get Bo that was ridiculous the Wuhan
Institute of rology I got suspended for
that so I know that was a big deal but
the point was it was about not
preventing the sharing of ideas not
about not saying things that were
offensive well but see this is the issue
is that this is still an idea because
what you what you're talking about from
from The River To The Sea as you know
there are lots of people that don't feel
that it is a call for genocide I don't
believe them I don't I honestly I don't
believe them none of I think you think
every single person that has said that
wants to see a genocide I think the vast
not a genocide but they think that if
they think that it's fine to say it
should be a democracy where everybody
there gets a say and the Jews would be
Jews and then it should be a one-state
solution and the Jews would end up
getting slaughtered I'm I'm sorry people
get mad at me for this but I don't care
if people started marching marching
around doing Roman salutes while uh uh
you know doing a SE are you going to be
like not everybody actually believes
when Hamas puts out their Charter and
they include we we read this this
morning on the culture War hamas's
original charter included the the the uh
I think Phil mentioned it was one of the
hadiths which quite literally says the
trees and the stones will call out
there's a Jew hiding behind me so that
the the Muslims can come and hunt them
and kill them down kill them and their
Charter actually says that the there
will not be Judgment day until they've
killed the Jews like you can it's fair
point not everybody May mean that but
that would be akin to you know people
going around doing a Roman salute or
I'll give you a better one I've seen
I've seen I saw a family extended family
member of mine do the red salute at a
March and I'm just like it's so funny
how many the fist the fist where you
show the fingers forward and the reason
why they do that so there's there's the
victory fist where you can like hold
your fist in the air and shake it but
the red solute is when you hold your
fingers forward and I'm not going to
make the fist on camera and it's because
it represents that each IND indidual
finger is weak but together is strong
and you show your enemies so when I see
people doing that I'm like I understand
they don't literally want to to Massacre
and Slaughter a bunch of people and they
don't literally want a communist take
chanting from The River To The Sea by
all means we can say maybe that person
doesn't really know but nonetheless you
have a large group of people expressing
the idea of Hamas yeah and hamas's
stated goal of wiping out Jews I I don't
disagree with with what would you think
about if they let people say it with
video in chat video chat but if you type
the words on the network that gets
blocked or banned the wait I'm sorry I
so we could say from The River To The
Sea we could say all the words that got
elon's blocking or Banning if we were
able to say it in video chat it would be
okay because they can hear the tone they
can see that we're talking about the
idea but if we type it onto Twitter it
gets blocked or banned I see I still I
still would rather not because of the
ambiguity of this of the statement in
question right if you were expressing
the idea I think that that that Israel
should actually be pal
and it there shouldn't be any Jews there
like if you if you express that idea but
many of them don't believe that they do
believe that there shouldn't be in
Israel they believe it should be
Palestine but they also believe that the
Israelis should just be folded into
palestin I don't think you get that I
don't think that's an option that's
that's think well many of them do
believe that when they say it and and
and they're to be to as Fair as I can
must be wrong because uh I just every
time I ask the question what would
happen if the if the barriers are around
Gaza were removed and all Palestinians
were allowed free reign in Israel what
would happen Will Chamberlain says
outright this morning the the the most
devastating pogram we've ever seen and
the first thing scottt you know brings
up is something of the right of return
and
then I got to be honest you I don't see
how a person could argue the land
belongs to them it was stolen from them
and then someone would say but if we
allow them all free movement within this
territory there would would not be
conflict of some sort well I agree there
would be conflict well Scott actually
responded with to to will in saying the
Israelis are not disarmed as if to imply
it wouldn't necessarily be a pogram it
would be people getting shot and mass
violence of some sort I don't want to
speak for Scott I like the guy yeah but
my point is I think there would be
violence I I I and I hate bringing this
I don't even care about bring making the
issue specifically about Israel my point
is the left lies about everything all
the time sure and the weakness we face
is that the classically liberal ideals
and I don't mean modern liberal but the
like as Phil mentioned we take their
arguments in good faith and try the try
our best to to live and work together we
are just they they just uh run us over
the coals every single time not every
time that's not fair to say they lie
about everything every time is insane
that's not true and also the left now
you're making semantics because obvious
said it's hyperbole you're journalist
what everything all the time and then
you made it like that's a fact now let's
move forward and
the needless what you're saying is
completely needless it it conveys no
idea to anybody everybody know I'm they
say the sky is blue I'm like they lied
I'm talking about matters of substantial
consequence 90% of the time they're
lying that's also just a number you
pulled out of your ass I I I'm not
saying never lie but just be try please
be specific about it do whatever you
want but it's hard if you can't have a
real conversation I don't know what
you're doing here if the point is that
in every major news story Gaza Hospital
fake Gaza refugee camp fake they lied
about two of the biggest stories you're
talking about the the news organizations
that's I'm talking about theist the
activists who were on the street and and
Hamas activists I talk about when they
when they've lied about two of the
biggest stories pertaining to what
happened they're lying so when they when
they come out and they say oh did you
know Israel did this I'm like oh please
am I going to fall for this again I
don't know are you believing everything
that the Israeli government's telling us
happening too yeah it's like you can't
pin it on the left this this is what I
wanted to ask him about because he's
made this point a few times over the
past couple weeks and it's like I agree
I'm very upset in fact I had to put out
an apology tweet about that hospital one
because I felt so bad that I was mis I
was misled but this I mean this was
Major uh news organizations that were
putting this out so I you know the New
York Times to this day has an article up
saying that Brian snik was killed by j6
protesters I know look I understand your
anger towards them what I what I don't
understand is why that mislead is so
offensive to you which I agree with but
then the idf's leads when did I say it
wasn't well I but you've brought up the
the left is constantly lying it's like
but hasn't the IDF lied a lot too I
don't care about the IDF I care about in
the United States American Media
American universities American leftists
and liberals and people like Adam Schiff
and if I go down the list of every
single thing they've lied about and how
it is so it's the domestic policy side
is what you care about I don't care
about Israel I don't care about
Palestine I don't care about Myanmar I
don't care about a I care about the
humanitarian crises in these places as
much as equally as much as all of them
they're all bad but the issue is
domestic American leftists calling for
decolonization Etc they will come to you
and say we are simply saying that people
deserve some kind of reparations and
then when you turn your back they stick
a knife in it and I mean that
figuratively but when the New York Times
to this day has a story up that says
Brian snik was uh was killed I believe
snik was his name was killed and that
story is totally false and the capital
police issued a statement saying it was
natural C causes meaning non-external
meaning it was not homicide side and we
know for a fact that's true they lied
how come you got Thomas Massie he tells
the truth how come you got Matt Gates he
tells the truth how come you've got and
I'm not going to give all the
Republicans credit no but it is
consistently that you will read
prominent conservative Publications that
will be fair even to their own detriment
and liberal Publications lie the
majority of the time yeah in terms of
domestic policy sorry I the reason I
asked to clarify is because you know
from my vantage point we have had fog of
War deception on both sides of the
Israel pales War if you want to talk
about just broadly who's the most
fullish when it comes to domestic
news yeah it's clear I mean this is why
Trump came to power was he was telling
fake news and and I want to point I
we're going to jump to this next story
in a second but I have to point this out
as well Twitter what were Twitter's
biases biases no question left yep 100%
And they were actively working with the
United States intelligence agencies to
suppress legitimate information to in
order to win political power Donald
Trump in my opinion would be president
today if not for the intelligence
agencies going on Twitter and Facebook
and YouTube and telling them explicitly
you will not allow people to share
information pertaining to the hunter
Biden story I guarantee he he would have
won I guarantee it the polls show it
could be from like 6 to 10% but outside
of that let's imagine even Trump would
not have won we know thanks to Elon Musk
that the United States intelligence
agencies were going to Big Tech and
saying You must do these things vayia
Gade was having regular meetings with
them and I want to jump to and and I
want to add the election Integrity
partnership colluding with the US
government to censor me personally as
well as many other prominent individuals
in politics and they called me a super
spreader of misinformation why two
points one I retweeted I think I
retweeted jack pic and Elijah Schaefer
one time and that was their
justification to slander my name even
though I said Donald Trump did not win
and because typically my story is Led
with here's the lawsuits and the merits
must be heard and that is a threat to
their manipulation but how about this
one we have this story from Newsmax one
of the most important stories and I'm
gonna I I don't know I got to make some
phone calls to make this happen bitshoot
calls on rep Jordan to investigate
parlor deplatforming now this is
explosive stuff bitshoot a video hosting
social media platform is calling on Jim
Jordan to investigate the deplatforming
of parlor another social media website
popular with conservatives as part of
his house panel on government we
weaponization in a letter to Jordan
bitsh sho's Chief policy officer and
former policy Chief policy parlor Chief
policy officer Amy POF wrote that parlor
was likely deplatformed via the same
sort of coordinated effort that were
alleged in the select subcommittee on
weaponization of the federal
government's recent report on the
censorship industrial complex this is
explosive and is so far an allegation
but I believe it is fair to say that the
probability lies in them being correct
why did parlor get uni unilaterally
removed instantly from all these
companies smeared by the media instantly
all at the exact same time and it was
all fake news they argued that parlor
needed to be removed because January
Sixers were using it to coordinate
despite the fact they actually used
Facebook and despite the fact the New
Evidence that's emerged shows the police
were widely facilitating what was
happening it stands to reason that the
US government was threatened by the fact
that large amounts of political
individuals in the United States were
leaving Twitter for a rival platform for
which they had no control and we now
know thanks to Elon Musk whose purchase
of Twitter is one of the greatest acts
of heroism shout out Elon Musk because
we're learning this and when he leaked
the emails revealing that so that
Twitter with its left biased was heavily
influenced specifically by the US
intelligence agencies I would be I would
be willing to bet large sums of money
parlor was removed Alex Jones was banned
because of government intervention and I
say this is someone who has proven
definitively right now the US government
colluded to censor me personally we're
seeing this I would like to see Jim
Jordan Matt Gates and anyone else I want
to see the documents relating to parlor
because I'm willing to bet we are going
to see something like an email that goes
we're really concerned about parlor and
hey Apple by the way you do know that
facilitating terrorism is a crime in
this country right and January 6 was an
Insurrection you they used parlor heaven
forbid we accuse you of aiding and
abetting terrorism and then all of a
sudden parlor is gone well and keep in
mind too that the reason parlor got put
taken down was because Amazon web
services shut them down and I think that
they've got a lot of government
contracts they've benefited a lot from P
from the App Store well that that is
well that is well but I'm saying that
their actual they had to actually
migrate their servers because AWS
stopped doing business with them because
of the allegations that were fraudulent
from the federal government the federal
government has demonstrated time and
time again that they have their tendrils
into every social media network of any
magnitude whatsoever and parlor came
about kind of had this fast rise that
looked like it might actually be a
competitor for Twitter or something else
and they were like can't have that we
have our we have fought long and hard to
get our hands of the FBI the CIA DHS
everybody else into Facebook Instagram
Twitter every across the board and
they're like we can't have you guys
having another Outlet sorry so we're
going to make it go away and people
think that like this is where I get
pissed is that instead of us just just
talking about like I appreciate Tim's
anger about this because we ought to be
furious do we I mean do we know what
we're actually talking about this is the
land of the free right this is America
right and and we have all we just accept
the fact that every single thing we do
on the Internet is spied on by the
federal government you know when I was
when I was growing up that would have
been laughable and we would have never
even considered it a possibility now
it's a given think about how how far I
almost cussed How Far we' We've
transitioned if you will remember when
that D dni guy lied to Congress about
spying on the American people yes yeah
it was bu Clapper it was James Clapper I
with anger I I kind of feel like Art of
War style when you're angry don't show
it thing cuz I'm beyond like enraged
about the last seven years but I am
acting like I'm just this happy go-lucky
guy because I really want to change it
and if you get angry you become a Target
so I don't know if see I'm okay with
being a Target because I want people to
know that they're not alone in in their
exasperation like I I'm so exhausted by
the The Tyranny that we languish under
and there's a lot of people out there
that just accept it they just go like it
is what it is I reject that
wholeheartedly it is not it is not
necessary that we suffer this forever we
are I you know I don't go much into
Birthright type of stuff but if there is
a Birthright of every American it is
that we can speak freely we can defend
ourselves you know there's there's a
handful of like really sanro sank type
of beliefs and ideals that we uphold and
it seems like very few people take that
seriously they look at their politicians
that are constantly infringing upon them
and they accept it they just go it is
what it is Clint you know it's tyranny
that's where we're at that's not okay we
can't live like that if you expect the
America that we knew and loved to
actually sustain itself to to be there
10 20 30 years from now we have to
actually vocalize our our anger towards
the system and actually demand that it
change and I appreciate your kind of you
know Buddhist outlook on it but I really
think that that it there needs to be
some anger demonstrated even if it puts
the sights on me I just don't care I
don't the um it it may be that it's
Unstoppable the corruption is
Unstoppable that we need to build
systems that can't be tampered with like
parlor should have been a system that
couldn't be taken down like a
decentralized web Network that like a
mesh Network or something where the
govern's like how do we hit this whack
thing it's Unstoppable I'm sure could
they do it over they would they would
have done so but the truth is they're
gone you know parlor is basically gone
at this point cuz like in a in a the
rise of a social media this is what's so
nefarious about it in the rise of a
social media Network there's this I mean
there's the exponential growth phase
that you have to hit if you're going to
succeed and if you don't hit it or if
you're if you're derailed mid that uh
you know that exponential rise you're
toast so all the all the federal
government has to do from here on out
like like EX actly what they're doing
with Tik Tok threatening that they're
going to ban Tik Tok I'm not a fan of
Tik Tok that's not the point you give
them that precedent you allow them to
just shut down one of the most
successful social media apps of all time
maybe the most successful and what do
you think they're going to do from there
well all of a sudden Elon mus acquire
his Twitter got to ban that right
because we already have the president
he's he's allowing he's allowing some
sort of CCP propaganda to be pushed do
you think
on on a long time frame you know 1002
200 years do you think that there is the
possibility that we're going to not have
constant monitoring and and constant you
know the
government or or maybe not even just the
government but constant OverWatch from a
from a large entity because I know that
there's a lot of people that now are
speaking very you know we can't let this
happen and blah blah blah blah blah
Etc because this is still new stuff
I don't think in two generations
anyone's going to even think about not
being monitored all the time well
because I don't think that I don't think
the option I I think that there are
teenagers now that just accept it as
part of reality of course it's a part of
the like it's a part of living in modern
society and I don't see how that's going
to be I don't again like I don't see the
offramp I don't see how how we we we
convince people that the convenience is
not worth it because that's really what
it's what it's about often times the
pendulum doesn't swing back until the
pain is great enough right and and I
feel like the reason I'm so loud about
this stuff is that you're right Phil
that like the vast majority of young
people because we've got forever like
like just barring some kind of like
Extinction event it's this this problem
never goes away for the rest of the time
that there are human beings well the the
surveillance capacity never goes away
but that doesn't mean that you can't
have rules and regulations that apply to
the government as far as what they're
allowed to do and what criminal
punishment they have to pay if they
violate this how I don't see how we get
any kind of rules or regulations it's
going to happen in some in some
countries it just like do you want it to
be here no no I don't you don't think
it'll happen anywhere on Earth I I don't
think that there's going to be I don't
think that there's any society that
currently has the ability to force their
government to do anything anymore damn
that's dark you got to build wait till
the AI takes over I know that's honestly
I mean we've had this conversation Tim
like I like once you get you know chips
that can are implanted in most people's
brains and again these are problems that
don't go away this isn't like oh we'll
solve it this generation and then we
don't have to worry about it in the Next
Generation or the following generation
or three generations down once this
Genie comes is let out of the bottle
it is something that for as long as
there is
industrialized commun uh you know modern
society this problem does not go away I
see like the law evolving to computer
software code so like instead of having
a law on a paper somewhere like I hope
we're all abiding by that thing it's
actually part of the structure of our
ability to communicate the laws are
written into the way things work so
there's no ability for a government or
foreign entity to violate the law or the
the code of the system you're you're
you're you're neglecting Pirates you're
neglecting to think about real meat
machines that don't want it's kind of
like saying like hey send me some send
me an ice cream cone on Twitter you
can't because it can only send certain
types of things because the code is such
that only certain types of things can be
transmitted so if that's your system you
can like you know observing from the
outside isn't part of that code system
considering the conversation that we've
had so far tonight talking about what
was done to part
what makes you think that that will ever
be a possibility what what benefit how
like why would the people that currently
control the levers of power why would
they allow that because right now I
think that there's an that there's the
people that the powers that be have
enough control where I think it's
already too late I think you could still
build it using like blockchain
technology and have decentralized yeah I
don't think I don't I think that I think
that it it'll take it would take uh the
will I I think that the that people
don't have the will to push back against
it because that's what I'm working on to
modern society is so convenient your
average kids don't know what they like
that we see Tik toks and we make jokes
about Tik toks all the time of of kids
that don't have any idea how Society
Works gen Z 2021 80% supporting samesex
marriage 2023 65% I'm not making a moral
statement I'm saying opinions shift
dramatically and things could I've
noticed if you spend a lot of time with
autistic software developers you're
you'll get a lot more hope because they
all already know that it's possible it's
just you're just constantly going to be
chasing the tail it'll be we'll create
new systems that can't Beed with and
then I just want to add something as a
total aside um because I I you you
mentioned something made me think of
this and I checked crickets are already
in your food you're already eating
crickets yeah and so uh they don't they
don't list the ingredient as Cricket
it's called aeda and so this this it's
not ubiquitous but the the products
exist where you might not realize that
the cheesy puffs you bought will say in
the ingredients you know like cornflour
cheese enzymes acheta yada y y and then
you're like I don't and you don't
realize that they put Cricket in there
without telling you a chetta is a genus
of cricket yep so I saw this on Facebook
you mentioned something about where
we're headed and eating the bugs and all
that stuff and I you look it up and it's
like yeah that the ingredients list will
say aeta see I am I am totally I am
totally unprepared to accept the
inevitability that I will be eating
crickets for the rest of my life you you
might surve for the rest of my life I
just I reject it outright I will not go
along with this no matter how
challenging it is I'm saying that this
problem doesn't stop because we think we
found a solution for this here the it's
the same thing that rean said problem of
Freedom
verus yeah exactly like like Reagan said
Liberty is never more than one
generation away from being lost exactly
and so this fight isal the failure that
we have or the failures that have now
compounded
to produce young people that are saying
Osama Bin Laden was right the failures
are ours they are gen X's they are the
Boomers they are they belong to the
Millennials well no no no I will add
this it it is entirely possible that it
is not our fault that young people on
Tech Tok are doing these things if
you're walking down the street and
someone lobs a snowball at the back of
your head and it hits you is that your
fault that happened right China Tik Tock
influence operations we may have just
been caught off guard and not so you
could make the argument well you should
have known it was possible and that's
fair if you're walking down the street
in neighborhood and it's snow everywhere
you should realize there's a chance
someone might throw a snowball at you
and so you should be you know Vigilant I
suppose though getting hit with snowball
is not the biggest deal in the world
should we have been prepared for Chinese
run influence oppos operations in this
country yes but I think it's fair it's
possible we can say it's not any
generation's fault they just attacked us
I'm still I still haven't seen like much
along the same lines of these Iranian
back militias and these Iranian backed
funded trained every every time the us
or Israel is struck it's always Iranian
back like that's immediately what they
report I've never seen any evidence of
it similarly I've never seen any
evidence of the the China like the CCP
actually modifying their code for the US
version of Tik Tok to propagate
something that's destructive cuz they
don't they have a separate code for they
have a different it's it's a totally
different company in
China same okay so but but so so hold on
when when uh uh the start of the Israel
Palestine conflict there were uh 10 to1
Pro Palestine posts versus pro-israel
yet the pro Palestine posts were getting
no
views after one like almost like a day
into the next week the views went
tenfold and so that's indicative of an
algorithmic change I'm not saying I know
for sure my point is Tik Tok is loaded
with values that are subversive to the
United States and it's a Chinese run
company it's owned by bite dance yeah
which owns T buzz video
capcut by by.com Pico lemon8 tweet oh
yeah if you use cap cut to make videos
you're sending those videos directly to
China so I assume their code is is not
public right all proprietary yeah it's
all private code well then I guess we
won't know but to be fair well Tik Tok
maybe Chinese Communist propaganda
Facebook and YouTube are American
Communist propaganda exactly so and this
is why I I struggled to like get my uh
whatever that term is get I I I can't
really get upset about Tik Tok when it's
like well I have my own government no I
I disagree I mean we absolutely look the
United States does bad things all the
time but we're being actually attacked
by a foreign adversary to destroy our
future Generations that's that's pretty
pressing well no it is but the the
difference between you and I is that I
perceive the federal government's
manipulation of us as also attack of our
future generations and our current one I
I view the federal government in America
as a far greater threat than any foreign
government on Earth no I think way wrong
being totally honest you think that if
you were you were conquered by the CCP
you'd be like this is better than the US
government that's not that's not what
I'm saying there there are other
governments that are far worse my point
is the great the greater threat to me
and my loved ones at present is the
federal government of America that you
understand the distinction I I yeah I
get it I get it okay cuz like do I do I
actually like like do I think that the
CCP is going to come over here and
actually mess up my life probably not do
I think that the the feds well okay fine
in in the periphery but I'm saying the
feds could actually put me behind bars
tomorrow because I said something on my
podcast that's and but this is the
worrying thing okay okay uh if with with
we see this every day with Tik Tok the
we we we got banned from Tik Tok we
created a new account I guess what
you're allowed to do I don't know the
list of things you're not allowed to
talk about on Tik Tok it's basically if
you are an
lgbtqia A2 plus communist you're
fine anything else so we actually have a
list of because because we follow the
rules doesn't matter if you follow the
rules there's there's secret Tik Tock
rules and so we're we're we're we have
like we have a social media list of like
okay here's the things that if no matter
what no matter what you say you mention
it they ban you mhm that's Tik Tok Tik
tok's list is massive Facebook is pretty
bad and YouTube is actually the least
bad I'm sorry X is now the best right
that you can you can say a lot on on X
is Rumble not better than x Rumble and X
are comparable okay I think rumble's
probably better okay yeah yeah but but
yes in in terms I only I don't even want
to bring up X because it's kind of a
given but considering it was originally
part of the big three but but YouTube is
better than Facebook I'll put it that
way way see this is why Tik Tok is is
and Instagram are nuts no no I I agree
this is why I'm surprised that Phil was
okay with Banning of the The River To
The Sea and the decolonialization
because it's like we fought so hard we
were so thrilled to see Elon take over X
to to kind of liberalize the the speech
Dynamics there but yet this is this is
such a danger that you're okay with it
it's it's it is the greatest danger to
the United States decolonization and and
the the the
left the cultural reevolu that we're
going through right now is
unquestionably the greatest threat to
the United States and to the society the
people that live in the United States
absolutely I think the more imminent
threat is World War III but I will agree
with you that the Marxist Revolution is
is a close second from my perspective
that doesn't change the fact that I
don't believe censorship actually
addresses a Marxist
revolution in fact I I I I agree I think
it could seek to embold in it if and it
would radicalize them extremely it would
not radicalize them they're already
plenty radicalized they are already
that's the exact argument they make
against the alt-right they say you can't
radicalize them already they're already
radical then they go over to you know uh
Pepe Central and then they get a lot
more radical yeah but when you go to
when you deal like right now on Twitch
there are people that constantly have
conversations what do we do with the
police after the revolution right
they're like what do you do with the
cops once you've dissolved the state
you're going to need the cops they're
already talking about the the precursor
con conversations to put them in the
Googs like these are the precursor
conversation what do you do with the
police when you've when you've got rid
of the state well you got to do
something with them because they're all
these people that know how to carry out
direct action stuff and what do you do
with them well what the Communists
historically have done is killed them
okay in these and and so these
conversations who's going to enforce
these these censorship protocols and who
are they actually going to go after
they're going to go after these these
black block kids are they going to go
after you and me so they're not going to
go out the the federal government I I
don't think the federal government
should be doing any of that because I
hav I haven't said I haven't said the
federal government should do any of it
I'm talking about if you're talking
about like uh like applic or uh ter
platforms and stuff like that and when
it comes to the actual like how do you
stop the spread of it it's getting get
out of schools get rid of P critical
pedagogy in schools get rid of all of
that Marxist stuff all the yeah all that
stuff let's jump to the story none of
stuff I'm talking about is is government
stuff I want I'm really looking forward
to reading this headline uh this is from
Fox News Lavar Burton threatens to
strike women because they don't like his
books uh here's a real headline Lavar
Burton accused of threatening physical
violence against moms group at book
award ceremony so what he had said was
are there any moms for Liberty here no
then we won't have to use hands is that
what he said yeah some hands or then
hands will not be need will not need to
be thrown tonight this is a really
shocking thing to hear the and and the
question is how do you get to the point
where Lavar Burton doesn't know and
doesn't care about pornographic material
being given to Children uh I want to
give a shout out to Taylor Hansen put up
a great video on tennet tenet media
watch him on YouTube he goes around
asking people do you think they should
ban books from schools and they're no no
of course not and he goes okay read this
for me and then they go no
he's like should that be in school no
and he's like okay well those are the
books they're banning and they're like
oh so uh how do you have someone like
Lavar Burton uh I view this as the
banality of evil right this is to me the
same thing as the guy doing the salute
to Hitler without knowing why why heing
or or caring about what Hitler's plans
were this is a guy who is saying he is
threatening physical violence what you
call it a joke call whatever you want he
actually said we don't got to throw
hands in reference to moms who are like
please don't show my kids porn right the
name of the group is actually moms for
Liberty and he's like I don't have to
throw hands with these moms it's like
you think you're the good guy how how
crazy is it that we've gotten to this
point where people are just like yeah
we're going to threaten violence against
women because of the ideology and by the
way that ideology that they uphold
they're like fans fans of the Bill of
Rights threaten to strike women yeah
he's threatening to strike women and we
got to this point in
2014 201 so a decade I know that I've
been taking heat for saying no you don't
punch Nazis forever and the reason you
don't is because it is
illiberal because we're a liberal
country and if you are going to actually
engage with ideas you don't get to say I
don't like your ideas so I'm going to
punch you and that it started out with
punching Nazis and everyone was afraid
to say no you don't want to punch Nazis
because everyone's afraid of sounding
like they're defending Nazis you don't
punch Nazis but you also don't censor
commies Phil no uh commies aren't people
so there's a different there's a
different thing no but that's that's a
legitimate legal statement and I know I
know this an important distinction right
Josie uh pointed out the the 1964 Civil
Rights Act actually excludes Communists
and that's kind of crazy incredible it's
because it's an idea it's not a it has
nothing to do with real it's
extraordinarily based but I still
disagree with it I believe in free
speech even for Communists even if
they're not people I don't um that's
fine so but any but yeah so I I lost my
train of thought there well let me just
add something real quick because uh kind
of real breaking news was that Paramount
Global is also now suspending
advertisement on X so you know have
Disney Warner paramont Global and
Lionsgate basically everybody that makes
movies in this country is uh sus this is
It's a coordinated assault it is related
to parlor related to Elon attacking the
Deep state it has nothing to do with
anti-Semitism they just need an excuse
yep boycott these companies subscribe to
timcast.net wire subscribe to Liberty
lockdown. locals.com uh and uh at
Liberty lockpad on Twitter look I am
very disturbed at this is like another
iteration of the same ESG Dynamic that I
I was kind of talking about very
aggressively a couple years ago is that
you have this manipulative uh you know
these tools now where the federal
government is able to influence private
business to circumvent our god-given
rights the Bill of Rights that's what
they do that's exactly why the ESG
framework exists that's exactly why de
Dei exists is that there are there are
constitutional protections that they can
get around as long as they use these
allegedly private entities to do so and
this is why I don't support any sort of
censorship on social media especially
when you realize that it's not usually a
private entity that is making these
decisions there is a lot a lot of this
is happening from a very high level
where they're essentially manipulating
the broader public and they're they're
controlling the dialogue and the dynamic
between us as as human beings this is
the the whole reason Elon allegedly
bought X was that he understood that if
we didn't have conversations with one
another we would end up fighting each
other in the streets again and we're
we're headed back towards that because
these people are trying to make him
they're trying to force him into a
course correction by by absorbing his
Advertiser Revenue that's what they're
doing it's clear sorry Phil no it's just
that that the the idea
that that phrases can't be said is one
thing it's different when you're talking
about ideas that can't be shared so the
idea behind and I think that it's okay
to say you can't save from The River To
The Sea because that is a
shorthand slang essentially a slang term
for an idea explain your idea because if
you explain it then you can't hide
behind from The River To The Sea do you
mean kill all the Jews is that what you
mean what are you talking about don't
don't give me from the river to the Sea
tell me what you mean and then they go
it means that Palestinians will equal
rights well again but then then it's
dragged out into an actual conversation
and you can talk to him which is again
the problem isn't the problem isn't we
need to ban these ideas from being
shared when you say we don't want these
phrases what you're saying is we don't
want you to be able to hide and that's
essentially what it boils down to is
they hide behind these phrases Banning
these phrases is actually how you force
these people back into hiding let
because you make them actually
articulate their idea I'm not saying you
kick them off or get rid of them for
being he's talking about saying that if
you're if you're genocidal he he
said Fair Point to Phil they will now
have to explain what their argument for
decolonize is instead of just saying
decolonize and every time we he that's a
fair point every time we talk about from
The River To The Sea people talk about
no well it means this and it doesn't
mean that it and it then it gets all
real you know real tough to nail down
what they're talking about which is
something that the left thrives on
that's part of the reason why they part
of the reason why they don't have a the
that's part of the reason why they use
the same vocabulary but don't use the
same dictionary because they want to be
able to hide their intent that's
actually a tactic they use but but you
you've already admitted that they they
lie you've emphasized that a lot so what
do you think I mean like I just don't
understand how oh now we've banned these
four words in this in this particular
order so now they have to explain it
differently and that's going to somehow
help us like if they type from the C to
the river well that also what if they
type
fttc well exact this is but this is
exactly what my Camp had to go through
the years ago when it came to co I had
to shift all of my language to try and
stay out of the censorship well it's
still the case gen Z says un alive they
don't say kill exact it's really
neurotic when you see like the f word
with a star where the U is just cuz
they're like I'm afraid that Daddy's
going to demonetize me afraid it's a
fact they it's so such just a show
that that people are afraid that if they
type a couple of letters it's going to
drastically change their life like but
it does but it shouldn't is my point and
agree and if people go on YouTube and
they say so and so killed you get
demonetized instantly if you say un
alived you're fine You' be the word
killed with like an exclamation point
for the eye and
you're you already aren't allowed to say
I'm going to kill this person or kill
that person these the that's not talking
about if you if I want to do a story
where I say police officer accused of
killing teenager I'm demonetized
instantly if I say you I have to come up
with very clever ways to explain it
because it's not a human being that is
telling me what to do it's a machine
that doesn't understand anything so Al
you got to use clever things like teens
life lost after police you know a police
officer fires weapon and then it's like
people know what I said but the
algorithm doesn't I'm basically having
to do a cap CH with every title I make
in a video right I kind of align with
with letting the Network owners ban
whatever they want I think that we're at
that point I don't want the government
to intervene and say you can't do that
with your speech if El wants to ban all
women and everyone that typed the letter
i he can do it it's his network but
that's also why I want these people to
have to free their software code so if
you abuse your network like that he can
start one with that same code all of the
code is is you can check the code on on
X not all of it some of it some of the
algorithm he freed uh but I don't know
according to Bill who I talked to CEO
minds.com bill up and he said there's
like 80% more to do well I I mean yeah I
I I think that that I think that that's
part of my problem with your your your
take on freeing the code and stuff most
people don't know and they're going to
have to go to someone else to ask anyway
even if it was freed you're going to
look it and be like what is this person
most people like it doesn't like and and
most people like so you're you're still
going to outs Outsource the information
to someone you trust but what happens is
if Clint's got the network and he's
abusing it because he's Banning people
that are typing the word okay and but
then you spin up the same network and
you don't ban people that say okay I'm
going to switch off his and go to your
network and it's going to be seamless
because the code's interoperable so I
can just go to whatever network has
better terms how much does it cost to
like hire a coder to make a version of
Twitter one guy to probably take about
17 years and about 900 million it would
take a long time and then you got to
imagine Twitter's building every moment
that you're building so they're
constantly getting ahead of you and they
have more serious question like if
someone wanted to spin up something that
was akin to Twitter right now how much
money would they need let's let's much
money how many hours would it take one
guy to build I didn't say one guy I'm
talking about someone wants to start a
company guy okay okay a guy wants to
start a company and he's like we're
going to compete with Twitter in the way
you're describing like this is a real
question what is the capital required
for someone to compete with Twitter it
be man hours how many man hours do you
need um how many coders do you need how
many hours will it take how much do the
coders cost it's a lot I don't know it's
a lot are we talking like $100 million
I'm asking seriously it's a legitim
question I think it might you need to
run keep it thing running which is super
expensive cuz I mean he all right so
just put it like this Elon acquired
Twitter for what 54 billion 4 44 billion
44 billion okay so if he could just
build it for 200 million well then
obviously the network effect and all of
the users matters tremendously so that's
that's the premium he's paying IP so
that's that's that I don't think there's
a one for one there no it's not but I'm
just saying I'm just saying it's it's
got to be significant to build one from
scratch uh well right I'd imagine it's
going to be like a 100 million yeah try
not to think of it in terms more about
you could probably like look mins exist
and mines has a lot of this
functionality too it didn't cost that
much money how much did mines cost to
get to where it is uh how many it's more
about hours cuz like guys can work for
cheap or they can work for expensive
itn't so there's an average there's
there's there's a median salary for for
software developers and backend and
front end and and full stack etc etc
probably oh my gosh off the top of my
head three 300,000 man hours is that
about right sounds like a lot that's
make one more point about let's say what
is it what is it 70 70 bucks an hour or
something roughly I mean yeah roughly
but like the CEO was working he's worth
like $1,000 hour so that's 210 million
yeah I mean this number is off the top
of my head without really thinking too
deep about it do my one guy does I could
be wrong 50 hours a week 21 million and
this is why the the concept of freeing
the code to the extent that someone
could create their own version is
impossible because like every other time
this has been this has been attempted
before too the what you're describing it
results in companies abandoning the
project because of a lost investment
right it just be duplicated if the code
I mean if they did that that would B
because then someone would just pick it
up and keep keep it running no they
abandon it there's tons of like if Elon
abandoned Twitter someone would pick it
up and keep running it but he but he
would abandon it it what happens is if
someone's like it's it's not about
saying we're going to stop the company
and cease to exist it's hey how much
does it cost for us to spin up a company
it's going to cost about $200 million
and then once we do the government will
seize all of our intellectual property
and give it away for free okay we don't
do that yeah exactly it would prevent
the the investment from the from the
get-go well you don't you don't free it
until it is in the Commons and I there
will be justification for it being
useful to the the people do you mean
like once it reaches a certain level of
us yeah yeah I wouldn't want to then
every company would say we're full sorry
only 999 million allowed yeah that's
probably true I'm not going to give up
billions of dollars of investment and
man-hours to the
government no no no private no private
entity is going to want to give up power
to the government but that's not what
antitrust laws are for it's not about oh
sir may I take your power from you it's
no you've developed something that we
the people utilize so we the people are
taking control of it and the point is
people would look at look at the
investment and say so the company in the
initial investment round when they're
discussing their plans they're going to
say the project we have in mind is
called uh twixer where you can post
these photos videos and share ideas the
uh growth period we're looking at is
going to be over 5 to 10 years the
initial investment we're seeking is
going to be around $200 million we'll do
it multiple rounds and we expect a cap
at 999 million for regulatory reasons
there will never be more users than that
and that's if you're going to make
social media Network to make money
you're in it for the wrong reasons oh it
doesn't matter come on you that's not
what this this is not a moneymaking
scheme what are you talking okay okay
hold on Ian your morals are fine doesn't
change anything I just said about what
you would how would you do that you just
stop letting people in at 999 you've
been in investment meetings yeah okay
investors are going to say here's our
business plan they're going to say uh
the the the investors are going to say
what what are what are okay thank you
for your plan we see how you're going to
make money we see how many users are
going to have or we see how much it's
going to cost now what are the pitfalls
every everyone who's pitching to
investors has to also include here are
our risks and they're going to say well
as you know the US government has
implemented a law at a 1 billion user
account after 100 million users your
code becomes public property therefore
we avoid this by putting a cap at 99
million and then the other guys don't
and they go up to 900,000 th million 9
billion users or four billion users and
they're still getting ad Revenue even
though their software Codes free here's
here's where I think you're both
probably a little bit off base is that
in reality once you get to 99 million uh
users you would just buy off a
politician to give you a cutout and then
you would grow above that threshold
anyway I I gotta be honest it's actually
much simpler than that okay they say uh
once we start exceeding 99 million we
start having a runoff room called twer 2
which is a separate company that will
that will have a networking through
madon which will the users we will avoid
the regulation the fundamental problem
that you're just glossing over though is
once you have insecure property rights
like you're describing right so it
becomes once it hits a certain level
then the it becomes nationalized if you
have insecure property rights those kind
of problems I'm not talking about
nationalizing anything but continue well
okay so if you if if you can't invest
and then take the result the the
benefits of of the investment that that
kind kind of insecure return on
investment it travels through your whole
economy and it screws up your whole
economy that's one of the reasons why
socialist countries don't work no one
wants to invest in a socialist country
if they're not going to get the return
on their investment but you don't lose
the code when it becomes free you still
have your network it still functions
exactly proprietary not but there's a
lot of value in not having competitor
you're basically offering as many
competitors as possible we should ask
Sam Alman what he thinks about keeping
his priv his code private at open a now
he's been ousted from the company he has
no access to the code now all that code
that was built by his company is no
longer he doesn't he can't read it
because it's private and we're all
wasn't open AI supposed to be an open
source nonprofit it started off as a
charity and then in 2019 they made it a
private so good so I'm glad he lost it
all Elon Musk talked about this because
he gave a lot of money saying how did
this turn from a nonprofit public good
into a private Corporation to enrich
people yeah exactly man social
networking Sam Alman being booted no
it's the danger the that like that that
code belongs to some foreign entity now
it's we don't know who bro bro but but
things belong to people all the time
like like rock locked Martin owns
powerful warships yeah I know oh no
Heaven someone's got a gun sometimes
people don't own them or we collectively
own things like the roads or things that
we own do we collectively own the roads
yes the humans as soon as the government
says you can't get on that road that but
actually you're you're you're wrong
especially in Chicago there's a company
that actually owns them that they they
own the rights to the roads the rights
but they can't shut the roads down
whenever they want they can do a lot
more than that they can have your car
destroyed they can take your car from
you and the government that's a
dangerous precedent man absolutely
thanks for thanks for agreeing with me
that privatizing certain entities of
reality are dangerous no no no
monopolizer government could put us all
in prison tomorrow monopolizing via the
government who then sells your rights to
a single private entity is a disaster oh
wait you got to say that again that
didn't make any sense okay so in Chicago
what happened was the city sold the
rights to all to to the streets to a
single private company why what the hell
what happened uh it's been 20 years
since I've been in Chicago more than
just naming rights no no like they they
had the rights to enforce uh uh uh uh it
was it was for parking specifically but
this means that if you're on the road
and the private company deems you to be
in violation they have your car towed
and they could have it destroyed that is
not a good path yeah it's so this is the
the the it's fascism right the lucrative
merger of state and and corporate
entities to uh subvert but but uh I I
digress the ultimate Point here is that
when you say at a certain level the IP
of the company should be released to the
public for use the issue
becomes one that it's an impossible
standard to uphold people will just
bypass this in various ways like uh I
think you brought this up that when uh
rockefeller's uh gold rock was it
rockefeller's Standard Oil Company he
just got richer when they did it they
broke it into six companies and he had
stock in all six of the new companies so
he got even more wealthy I don't think
breaking companies apart is the way to
go most of those guys that were were uh
attacked with any trust uh movements
they ended up being uh the progenitors
of the Federal Reserve like these once
you get to a certain level of power and
wealth and influence it's basically
impossible to use the government to
actually Crush these people because they
own the government it becomes yeah it
becomes a situation where it's they're
in conjunction with the government like
the the fact that there is it is like
FBI desks at like Facebook and at
that is ESS having the federal
government involved in the day-to-day
operations of these companies if you
open up a dictionary to Fascism it would
be a photo of an FBI agent sitting in
Facebook's headquarters and that's the
same thing that the CCP does there is a
cc there's a person that represents the
CCP at all of the companies in China so
I this is why I talk about freeing the
code because I think that if you wanted
to prevent these companies from getting
richer after their stuff is broken apart
you you just you allow the world access
to the software itself so that that
would that would that would the
government and the company no longer
have it anymore they can't control
anymore but also I think we should start
with Tik Tok and just force these
foreign any foreign social network that
wants to operate on us soil over a
certain amount of users fre for your
software code ag3 I got one I got one
better all social media companies must
publish the algorithm code their
recommendation algorithms must be public
the the the the proprietary IP for the
system functions outside of that they
can keep they also have to make it agpl
3 which is uh afren public license 3
meaning that any changes made to the
code are also publicly available so that
someone can't just take the the newly
public code into private and change it
and make it better you can't do that it
always stays like an ever expanding um I
mean these are city of blocks these are
all all laws that that would take the
government to enforce and as soon as you
have government working with companies
you you invariably get collusion that's
the reason go ahead no no no we're g to
jump so oh yeah yeah I mean that's the
reason why that that's the reason why
you have all these problems with banks
in the government is because the Federal
Reserve and the banks work together hand
inand and as much as like from the
outside it looks like they're working
together to take care of each other
they're trying to do what is going to
harm the fewest amount of people like
the reason that they bailed out the
banks in in ' 08 and stuff was because
they were trying to
trying to lessen the damage to the
economy which would have hurt everybody
so as much as I am for cutting the the
ties between government and the private
sector um I don't think that it's as
easy as we want wish it was is honestly
my my perspective we're going to go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net Lauren Southern and John
DUIs and it was executive producer was
Tim kest you got to check it out it's
about gun rights and gun culture and why
you should keep in bear arms but we're
going to read your super chats so now we
got fix bayonets with the first Super
Chat saying hi congratulations perfect
alpat turkey says by the sweat of your
face shall eat bread wait was that what
it says by the sweat of your face you
shall eat bread okay is that from
something I don't biblical passage I'm
not familiar with I don't
know all right what do we have
John McGee says judge has ruled that
Trump will be on the ballot in Colorado
so Trump has now won in Michigan
Minnesota and Colorado are there any
that are still in doubt uh there any
every every every other one I guess
they're all yeah I mean that's that
that's a good start for the Insurrection
guy apparently
though Jason Dixon says on Discord only
Kellen and serge timcast member only on
Discord tomorrow at 10 p.m. Eastern join
the Discord and join the community
that's right when you become a member at
timcast do.com go to timcast click join
us the instructions on joining the
Discord server are there and you can
hang out with uh like-minded individuals
who watch the show and they have uh uh
they run their own shows there's morning
shows there's after shows there's
pre-shows so there's a lot of stuff
going on you should definitely hang out
because building community and building
culture is the mission but what is that
you guys are hanging out Serge is that
what the plan is uh I don't know
everything exactly kellen's been kind of
taken care of it for me but I guess that
is the plan so right on we'll see yep
all right T-Rex Pet Shop asks Tim do you
know much about the new FCC regulations
on internet access what does it mean no
discrimination based on income level
free internet 20% off T-Rex Pet Shop
next week with Code Black Friday thanks
for that uh uh Super Chat as well as a
good ad for yourself I don't know enough
about it I've read only a little bit
yeah I don't I don't know what it
entails either but I can just tell you
based off of the the phrasing being used
it's almost certainly uh Dei style
framework which is diversity Equity
inclusion they're going to make it so
that uh they're going to push Equity
anytime you hear Equity you should hear
communism they're going to push Equity
when it comes to the internet uh service
providers eventually no white people
allowed on the
internet probably honly let's see what
we have here Spider-Man 200 says
remember Tim according to Jen those cops
are right Wingers fine so be it let's
play their game if they want to make
that argument then I will side with AOC
and say yeah all the capital police who
are hunting these people down and
building up these offices around the
country are insurrectionists they're on
camera helping them it's only possible
because they let them in lock them up
let's take each and every one of those
officers and put them in solitary why
not I'm down let's let's let's why are
we not asking the left for this they
want to expand the capital police to to
to a national level put him in Florida
and California okay well then Joe
Biden's an insurrectionist too Tim P
talking about arresting cops he's a
Libertarian for sure well you got to
arrest anybody who breaks the law know
and if those cops are on camera
facilitating an Resurrection Heavens
they should be they should get 20 years
each and every one of them you my point
is this if the GOP actually went to
those cops and said because of what the
what what is going on with law
enforcement we are going to make sure
that each and every one of you gets 20
years j6 would be over I agree I mean
particularly because many of them did
participate in a more sincere fashion
than some of the people that are doing
time right now if the police who helped
facilitate j6 were facing decades in
prison the Democrats would be like all
right all right you got us they would
drop charges on everybody yep I agree
and this is the problem with having a
two-tier justice system is that
ultimately there is no justice so we
need to start advocating that these
Capital police with these new release
tapes get two decades in prison because
what will happen is the likes of AOC The
Young Turks will agree with us there
will be a tremendous pressure on
Democrats Meritt Garland to start
indicting police officers which he will
not be able to do the police unions the
capital police they will lose it and
then you're going to see a massive
government institution say ain't no way
you're locking us up but uhoh the
Democrats base and the right are unified
on wanting that to happen yep but you
can't this the system will not allow
those cops to get arrested my concern is
that we have uh you know real weaponized
doj at this point and and once you get
there plus you have a real weaponized
intelligence agency apparatus with both
the FBI and the CIA it's like how do you
put that Genie back in the bottle I mean
this is the type of stuff that you saw
in USSR days you know and it doesn't go
in a direction that is favorable to
people that value uh walking freely at
all or eating adequately like this heads
in a very very dark Direction and I feel
like people aren't really facing it we
all like we look at it on the dayto day
we kind of realize it's headed in the
wrong direction but we don't actually
appreciate how precarious and how
imminently dangerous all of this is and
I'm not to freak people out but it's
like no they should be freaked out yeah
they probably ought to be yeah they
should be freaked
out let's grab some
more barely a millennial says the Deep
State and the left probably have dirt on
every elected person so nobody speaks up
or if they do nothing happens wouldn't
want those skeletons flung out of the
closet cowards oh you know it this is
how you know Thomas Massie has got to be
one of the cleanest dudes on the planet
cuz disagree he he bent the knee so he
he he bent his knee so fast for Kevin
McCarthy I thought he was going to blow
his
ACL I can't argue that yeah he said
didn't want to see the you talking about
when he said he didn't want the speaker
to be vacated just because he saw what
he was the one who wanted bner to be
vacated the institution will fall it's
like oh Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy's
blackmailing populist uh Maga candidates
there was a moment after I need I would
love to have a private conversation with
him to to find out like why why did you
have his back in that way it's bizarre I
there was a moment when there was no
speaker that we it seemed like maybe all
the Democrats were coming together to
with a few Republicans to put a Democrat
as the speaker and I was like oh hakee
Jeff I think and I was like that's what
Massie was afraid of is a complete and
total loss hold on hold on structure
you're you're correct but Jen Jen yuger
um was on the wrong side of this one the
uh Jimmy door was saying when the same
thing was happening with Democrats when
they took the house challenge them do
not give Pelosi the speakership unless
they give you concessions and Jen was
like no the Republicans will get in and
you'll get Kevin McCarthy don't do it
and that's just it's not what happens
there is not a single Republican who
would sacrifice their
career over over a vacant speakership
these people are cowards every single
one of them save okay to be fair maybe a
couple of them aren't handful so what
happens is the Democrats go to them and
say don't you want to be a Defector and
the guy's like here are my options I can
say nothing and no one knows my name or
I can destroy my entire life and career
and go home as an enemy of my own
neighborhoods and my own my own District
I'd rather just hide in the bushes right
so when it comes to the vote most of
these people were hiding in the
bushes until they finally got someone
everyone was comfortable enough to to
stand behind and go are you voting
you're you're voting for Mike Johnson
I'm voting for Mike Mike Johnson too
yeah oh yeah okay all right what what
bothers me is that this The Narrative
has been America First and that has been
what really Trump and all of the new
modern iteration of the Republicans I
don't despise have rode into power on
the back of has been the American first
narrative right but then you McCarthy
who I agree is a total traitor and
scumbag but then you put in Mike Johnson
whose very first priority is funding for
Israel right and it's like it's like can
I ever get someone who actually means it
when they say America First can I is it
possible but that's why they they they
voted for him cuz he probably went up
and said I'll tell you what first thing
I'll do we fund Israel and they were
like okay fine yeah at least we got the
j6 tapes he's better than McCarthy I
agree he's better than McCarthy but man
low bar
seriously let's grab some more Super
chats Josh field says I very rarely get
to tune into to the live shows and I
listen to the podcast at work I'm sorry
the culture War today was ridiculous
Scott just wouldn't stop talking and
never answered any question I just
couldn't finish it well I I will say
this uh because I think Scott's a good
dude we skated afterwards we had a blast
the the that was one of the challenges
when the show started people may have
noticed this Scott asked if he could do
a 10 a 15-minute opening statement and I
was like well it's entirely up to will
who's debating to the side I mean the
problem is that you're going to say a
bunch of things that will be challenged
and if you just say them and you're
asking no one debate you I mean this
creates an issue and that actually came
up a couple times where it's like you
know Scott would say it's it's it's I
would call it an unintentional Gish
Gallop I I I warned him of this before
the show I said are you familiar with
the debate tactic Gish Gallop it's where
you say as many things as possible once
so your opponent can't respond to them
and so this is the trouble with saying
five things and then saying wait and
then changing the subject and adding
another thing and saying wait and then
adding another thing because now we have
to stop and then you know will is trying
to write it all down and but you know it
is what it is I thought it was a good
show I thought it went
well let's grab uh let's grab some more
Super chats where we
at Mike O'Hara says should the kids
recording the death of the kid getting
jumped in EV had to be prosecuted the
guy that recorded the death of Amed
Arbury got prosecuted for not doing
anything but recording the incident well
the answer is no he should be freed too
right yeah he shouldn't have been
charged and I got to tell you man I I
this this is the worst story ever
because everyone's lying and it's coming
from the right here's the story of what
happened to Jonathan Lewis in Nevada a
group of kids stole headphones from
another kid Jonathan Lewis tried to get
the headphones back they refused a fight
was arranged between Lewis and this
group behind the school in an alley when
Jonathan Lewis went there demanding the
headphones be returned and they refused
he took a swing Jonathan Lewis swung at
a kid as soon as he did a group of about
six or seven rushed in the total group
you can see on camera that are beating
him probably is between you know it's
probably six or seven it it may be
around six and I I I watch the video I I
I got the full Clips where you can see
Jonathan LZ throwing the first punch uh
two of the kids are not black four three
or four may have been black what did we
get a guy tweeted that 15 black kids
beat a white kid to death that is
factually incorrect but by all means you
can say the kid shouldn't have died by
all means you can say that Jonathan
Lewis defending his friend was the good
thing and the right thing to do you can
say whatever you want about it I'm just
telling you what happened make up your
own mind but that story really grinds my
gears because I still people people I I
we you know I still have people saying
15 people beat them up I'm like did you
watch the video no okay well watch the
video there's two guys who are described
as swarthy meaning they could be uh
Asian they could be uh Middle Eastern
they could be Hispanic we're not
entirely sure it's a very grainy video
three three three or four of the
attackers appear to be black take take
for it what you will right I I'll
probably lose some uh some listeners
over this one but I got to say it
anyways I've been really Disturbed and
look let me start by saying yes there
are crimes that are perpetrated against
white people that don't go reported
because that doesn't fall into the
category of the victimhood uh you know
hierarchy that people are talking about
these days however I don't like how you
will have these viral videos of a
one-off Act that is from perpetrated by
a black person against a white person
and and then you'll see just the reply
segment is just filled with people that
are like hardcore you know uh I mean
white supremacist I think is a fair
thing to say but certainly uh abiding by
the white grievance politics type of
mindset and I just think it's very
unhealthy I just I'm I'm not interested
in going the opposite direction from
black people are always oppressed and
the white people are always the
oppressor and now we're going to flip
that and it's white people are oppressed
and I I don't want to
and I think there are a lot of people
that jumped on the 15 black kids beat
beat a white kid to death story because
it was it fits that role well we can
attack the leftist narrative exactly but
the only problem is it falls apart and I
and people in chat are asking where the
info is uh read the news I don't I don't
know like Google search it and watch the
video there's several videos the video
that went viral on Twitter is a short
clip that doesn't show you the fight
starting the the full video actually
does exist and you can watch it and then
you have conflicting statements and uh
uh then the police issued their
statement so I'm not telling you what
who who who who to blame who is right
who is wrong or whatever I'm telling you
what what the police and the news and
several different sources like between
them have have have stated and let me
add one more point is that it's not at
all empowering to start to get people
that have your skin color to feel as if
they're victims just because of how they
were born uh I think that this is
extraordinarily destructive to the black
community and I think that if you take
on that that belief system and you apply
it to white people it's also destructive
I would not advise it for either side
and in fact come together if you could
thanks Jesse JFR says I'm watching the
same people that said punchin Nazi say
from the river to the sea is it really
funny
right that's a good one that's a good
one Paul tascal says the contrarian
intellectual libertarian stick gets old
fast I'm fine with being a silly
American that hates Bin Laden you know
you're inflicting pain and listening
anger by defending Usama Bin Laden
anyway what's the point who's that for
oh I assume he's talking to me I I
didn't defend Osama Bin Laden if you
actually listen to it I was saying that
his grievances are shared by many people
that are not scumbag terrorists that
live in the Middle East who have had
their lives destroyed by the
military-industrial complex of America
that is that is a valid and and
reasonable claim that the American
population ought to consider given that
we have been robbed blind to pay for the
military apparatus that has destroyed
these people's lives I take that very
personally that my my hard labor has has
been stolen from me to go destroy
innocent people's lives overseas if that
doesn't disturb you that's fine you're
not like me I take it seriously and then
let me also add as I'm lecturing you
that just because I'm going to to point
out the legitimate grievances that Osama
Bin Laden had in that letter does not
mean that he is Justified in doing what
he did on 911 which was one of the most
egregious things that any human being
has ever done so I don't know walk and
chew gum
homeboy all right what do we have here
let's grab some super chats laugh out of
that
one let's see par daxus says Phil it's
already too late imagine if there was a
guy that died 2,000 years ago to rescue
us from the perils
coming so uh interesting I I guess okay
all right here we go Jim Hansen says
Clint we dispatched Iranians in both
Afghanistan and Iraq regularly and their
training is responsible for the E
emptied threat is that what you're
trying to say is it a typo there I know
they don't they don't cover that in
finance
world I don't follow what he said there
I'm sorry I think he's saying that there
are Iranians in Afghanistan and uh Iraq
or that they they dispatched them either
they killed them or saying killed they
killed them or they sent them off to do
something that's another I think think
it's distinct possibility that there
have been some Iranian people in the
Middle East as we've been over there but
the better question is why have we had
tens of thousands of American troops
over 6,000 mil away the the the the
euphemisms over whether or not someone
died it's getting a little ridiculous
instead of saying dispatched or un
alived just go with shuffle them loose
this Mortal coil
yeah simple that's very straightforward
very straightforward it fits in every
YouTube title
okay where are we at the Tex vet says
Fring the code wouldn't work if the code
was the reason a company can't compete
then explain parlor it monopol it's
monopolization and government
interference not the code well parlor
couldn't compete because the
government also it was a crappy piece of
technology compared to Twitter if that's
what you're talking about what do you
mean I don't know I didn't like it very
much it's pretty Bare Bones a government
that has what how is it any different
from Twitter Twitter's had all the same
functionality um I don't know if that's
necessarily true as far as anyone on the
front end could tell it was the same
thing a government powerful enough to
force a to free its code is also a
government powerful enough to put out of
business every competitor to any
particular singular business that they
want to be in a monopoly position I I I
I reject that libertarian argument it's
true a government that's power enough to
lock a man up for murdering another
person is a government that's powerful
to lock up an innocent person and claim
they murdered
someone yeah okay yeah right that his
argument doesn't follow it's like
basically saying like we want the
government to stop murderers but oh no
then the government might arrest
innocent people okay will create a
robust system that tries to preserve the
rights of the innocent fair but there's
still there's still a valid argument to
be made that if you if you have a
government if you empower the government
to strip their IP protection right
you're saying you're saying that they
have to free the code that's Ian's
argument well then they also have the
capacity to shut that company down if
they don't yes right okay so where does
that lead it means that it's they get to
choose winners and losers which means
that they can ultimately dictate who
gets to be the the dominant lead in the
industry and and so the issue with this
AR is it implies corruption has nothing
to do with the argument about whether or
not we regulate so to say a government
that can arrest a man for murder has the
power to lock up its political opponents
sure does so do we just stop arresting
people for murder well no of course we
just we we we we we just need to not
have corruption okay but my my argument
is that both sides of it are bad though
if you're if you're actually going to
try and use um what's it called
antitrust protections to to shut down
some of these Monopoly actors it's it's
totally fruitless they they ultimately
end up being in a even if they get split
up they still end up being in a very
dominant Market position because they
own the politicians that are dictating
that separation from the from the getto
yeah I don't want to shut down the
companies or break them up I want their
code to be accessible to the common man
so the government no longer has that
kind of power and authority over what
that network does because the network is
now proliferated I mean they could try
and send out 600,000 cease and assist to
600,000 different Twitter clones but you
know that's a lot more robust defense
mechanism than having one of them yeah
well I mean the network effect is really
why these social media companies Prevail
anyways because so many people have
accounts there so it's not really the
code it's the fact that people are using
the app right it's a combination they're
both very important okay we got a good
one it's massively important Marcus
aelia says my son was born a couple
hours ago we are in the hospital
watching timcast keep up the great work
Marcus reproduce homeboy let's go that
kid's on a good path America work guys
congratulations enjoy the
evening let's see what else we have in
the old uh old super chats spoon licker
says if we end up stuck with a 4,000
page Omnibus spending Bill someone needs
to add a line to repeal the Patriot Act
and dissolve the Department of Education
I'm saying this what I said when when
they we wheeled out the 5,000 page
Omnibus and said everyone just approve
it I'm like can't someone just slide in
like Trump one and just like put it
right in the middle
we got you that's how the Chinese do
contracts apparently they when you send
back Redline stuff they'll send stuff
back and they won't show you what they
changed they just expect that you're
going to reread it every time soorry I'm
feeling all I'm feeling very uh
reflective thinking about someone who's
watching us right now just had their
first child be born and how beautiful
that is it's just like such a cool thing
so pay attention to your wife yeah yeah
yeah sh close your phone dude as a as a
go name your son right as a total aside
just because I don't know I thought
about this I realized that every day we
do a show where I'm in the thumbnail I'm
taking a picture every day like those
people who do like a picture every day
so you could theoretically take I mean
how long have we been doing it this way
I think we have only only four couple
years three and a half years no but I
mean only a couple hundred episodes have
my face in them but that's probably like
just keep doing it man that's kind of
crazy you're going to see me like it
fatter and thinner and you know yeah but
that I mean that's all you'll see though
because you're part Asian so you won't
age at all so it's going to be like yeah
kind of boring well the way the way we
age is that we're totally the same until
70 and then turn into shorts
from that's pretty dope though that you
get to like be exactly how you are at 35
or whatever to 70 and then you just
become to be fair though that that that
myth comes from uh so you ever noticed
that in cartoons when a guy gets like if
if a if a kid gets turned into an old
person or whatever their pants go way up
yeah it's because older people back in
the day wore their pants higher today
they still wear their pants higher
younger people wear their pant pants
lower it's not that being old makes you
pull your pants up it's just that the
style of that yeah Asians don't look
normal and then at 70 shrink it's that
70-year-old Asians grew up in an era
where they were shorter and now the
younger generation of Asians are aging
more gracefully ah okay that's where
that TR comes from all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to Tim cast.com become a
member click join us and watch infringed
the new documentary by Lauren Southern
we're really excited we're going to be
making many more documentaries so a lot
of really cool stuff is to come and you
can also join the Discord server we also
have uncensored members only shows up
Monday through Thursday at 1 p.m. where
you as a member can actually call in and
talk to us and our guests smash the like
button subscribe to the channel you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Clint do
you want to shout anything El a couple
things uh we got Jackson Hinkle coming
in to the best political show.com it's
one word we are changed over on Rumble
Jackson ankle Sunday night 6 o'clock
don't miss it me uh Lukowski are my home
girl Steph it's going to be a blast it's
should be fireworks I hope to defend
Phil here's honor against the magga
Communist um I'm also the co-host of
tower gang and I am the primary host and
only host of liberty lockdown uh one
other quick
plug I got to mention it but don't
subscribe to it uh but we got LP
Connecticut uh their uh whatever it's
called their convention is the I think
it's the 7th of December myself Josie
the redhead libertarian m bunch of great
people are going to be there go to lpct
dorg I think to sign up and last but not
least @ Liberty Loot on Twitter please
do follow me uh I appreciate you guys
for having me back on it was a bless I
am Phil that remains on Twix I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can follow
us on Spotify Apple music Pandora
YouTube Amazon music you know the
internet and uh I'm Ian cross and follow
me on YouTube actually subscribe to me
on YouTube uh 1:00 Monday through Friday
Monday through Thursday I do interviews
uh Clint you've been on the show I was
just on last week it was great that was
really chill it was nice and uh today I
interviewed Dey long who actually
discovered the uh flash graphine process
where they're hitting gra carbon with
with electricity and turning it into
graphine this is the guy that like
figured it out it was really cool to
talk to him and also you were saying
don't subscribe to Tower gang don't
don't subscribe to Tower gang don't yeah
right that was what I the first one
thing I said all right don't subscribe
to Tower G Ian is the best marketer I
swear to God you got it talk to the
audience what's happening
Serge um I don't know what's going hear
your audio's Off Make It Rain brother I
don't know what's going on with the
whole thing on uh Discord but I think
Helen has worked some some situation out
where we're going to be chatting with
people that are on Discord so if you're
not a member of Discord please like Tim
said become a member uh you can talk
with us on the show and you can call on
the shows during the week normally
Monday through Thursday um that said uh
make America goth again is a shirt that
I'm wearing right now
and uh yeah you you conspicuous lack of
black lipstick for to be talked about
right right very no eyeliner no black
nail polish come on hey hey I said make
it again well one more quick note really
I'm going to implore the beautiful
timcast IRL audience go to liberty
lockdown on YouTube right now because
the show is ending and you ain't got
nothing to do there is no post show it's
Friday night go smash the subriel Bizzle
home Bizzle subscribe to liberty
lockdown Liberty lock will subscribe to
Liberty lown do not subscribe to Tower
gang that's the difference thank you
yeah do not subscribe Tower gang all
right when you ready Tim we'll see you
all uh next week thanks for hanging
out